foreign
security crash course your ultimate
guide to mastering the art of digital
self-defense in today's fast-paced
Digital World the DDOS attacks loon
hashing protects and penetration testing
reveals vulnerabilities we've got you
covered from thwarting DDOS attacks to
understanding the secrets behind hashing
from mastering the art of penetration
testing to safeguarding your digital
Fortress we will unveil it all today we
will be on a thrilling Expedition into
the world of cyber security
together we'll unravel the Mysteries and
Empower you to protect what matters most
and before we begin if you are someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete order
of the program being offered if you want
to kick start your career as a cyber
security professional in six months then
try giving a show to Simply learns
Caltech cyber security boot camp the
boot camp link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the Boot Camp Page where you can find
a complete overview of the boot camp
being offered and now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who've
experienced massive success in their
careers by opting out for these courses
[Music]
to all to learn anything new whether
it's an art a new language a new sport
or learning new skills to advance your
career hi I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old
and last year I upskilled with simply
learns postgraduate program at cyber
security after working 30 years in the
I.T sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course
yeah funny story I want to share with
you
I started off aspiring to be a DJ where
I became interested in electronic stereo
systems and how they connected and how
they operate and what made them function
and four years ago I began a journey to
understand and learn more about the
cloud on the way I develop a natural
understanding for the security needs and
began to focus my studies to understand
more about the cyber security aspect of
the cloud landscape
I work with many companies before the
security analyst and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at particulars in college
and been in many different learning and
training experiences but the experience
as a student is simply learning
something I will always cherish of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors I believe
in living a fulfilling life at 61. I am
still trained students in martial arts
I've been practicing martial arts for
the past 40 years and my efforts were
acknowledged by the Eastern United
States International Martial Arts
Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication Services martial arts I've
been many things in my life
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first
and if these are the types of videos you
would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press on the
Bell icon to now miss on future content
so stay tuned with us until the end of
this video and don't forget to register
your opinion in the comment section
below hey have you heard about Twitter's
data breach employees that are getting
leaked have you heard about LastPass
data getting breached have you heard
about Facebook getting hacked there are
so many news that we hear day in and day
out in this world and they are so common
in recent times we all know how big is
the scope of cyber security it's
increasing day by day statistics show
that over 1 million job openings will be
there by the end of 2023
and the fact is less than 50 percent of
individuals are actually skilled to do
the job less than 50 percent and even
after the Advent of AI it's the same as
digitization increases more and more
people are coming online more and more
businesses are doing their business
online coming up with their assets
online after covet there is 600 percent
increase in cyber attacks and I'm not
kidding and there is a big fact check
that every 38 seconds there is a
targeted Cyber attack happening
somewhere in the world so what is cyber
security cyber security is an industry
where we apply techniques and tools used
to protect a computer related system
namely software Hardware or a network
from cyber criminals or hackers and
honestly cyber security as a whole is a
very huge field when people say about
I'm getting a job in cyber security how
to get a job in cyber security there is
no job in cyber security as such you
won't get it there are many fields there
are many disciplines many domains inside
that so you need to to get a job inside
that because there are so many systems
diverse systems that have their own life
cycle to secure for example you might
have heard about different types of
softwares namely web applications mobile
applications maybe Android or iOS
desktop applications iot applications
and many more for a job in cyber
security you can be a destroyer or a
protector you can join both the sides of
the coin for an offensive job you hack
and find bucks for a defensive job you
identify attacks and stop them and this
is a very high level simplification of a
cyber security job even if you go inside
red team and blue team there are so many
different domains like namely appsec
Cloud SEC forensic investigator SOC iot
malware analyst incident responder and
so on and the most common jobs you might
have heard about in cyber security are
pen tester for offensive jobs vapt or
red team and for defensive job it's SOC
SOC analyst or a dfr analyst or a blue
teamer and if I go in deep on all the
domains will will be out of scope for
this video I'm here to give you a
general overview of every domain and how
to create a career potentially out of
that and I'll give you a roadmap for the
exact things that you will do and you
should do I cannot tell you exactly what
to do because there is no perfect
roadmap for anything and I'll just give
you the bare minimums and my
recommendations what I would suggest you
to do so let's get started but one
problem I wanna tell you but I can tell
you what to learn and how to learn it
but you'll need to find the resources to
learn because there are very scattered
there is no single course that can teach
you everything so the problem with
people is that they'll go there and
they'll find resources on Google they'll
learn from scattered resources and the
problem will be that they will not have
complete knowledge of the same domain in
deep they'll pick up voids between their
knowledge so it will affect their career
but what if someone shows you the exact
things to learn and make your industry
ready for a domain I'm gonna talk about
simply learns industry ready cyber
security program that will teach you
Indian find skills in just six months
and your career can be started right
away this program is Advanced executive
program in cyber security by simply
learn in collaboration with triple RT
Bangalore where you will learn this
in-demand skills from their top faculty
with real world scenarios and here you
will learn practical knowledge by
solving practical Labs with popular
tools including nessus and burp Suite
after the completion of your course you
will get a completion certificate from
triple it Bangalore in a transcript to
validate your learning apart from that
you will get a virtual internship from
npci National payments Corporation of
India in which you will get four
projects where you will have to solve
cyber security problems by identifying
issues or vulnerabilities in a system
and tell how to secure them sounds
exciting right so if you want to be
eligible for this program you need to
have a bachelor's degree at least and
one year work experience in any relevant
security field and some basic knowledge
of programming so if you are interested
then link is in the description go to
the link read all the description and
all the details click on apply now fill
all your details and just enroll right
away in order to learn cyber security
you need to First learn some
prerequisites it's not that easy to jump
directly into that so first of all you
need to love computers you need to fall
in love with them I am serious so first
of all the very basic skill you need to
learn is computer fundamentals so IO
input output software Hardware how
memory management is turned Disk
Management memory uh Process Management
Windows and Linux in both the OS and I'm
not kidding you need to learn system
administration level of courses you can
do a plus and then you need to learn
virtualization 2 how to run an OS over
OS and multiple OS and you can find all
those courses on YouTube you don't have
to wander around anywhere and waste your
time everything you can get free so the
next thing that you need to learn is the
most important thing they want to talk
about is computer networking that's the
most important thing no single computer
can be hacked if it's not connected to
anything else so there is no isolated
system in cyber security so you need to
learn how computers are connected the
basic TCP IP and OSI models and all the
layers inside that the most important
layers are data link layer till the
application layer so the application
layer is most important here all the
protocols that you will learn HTTP SMTP
FTP SSH and everything the most common
in web is HTTP so you need to be throw
inside that that is indirectly related
to internet internet runs on IP
addresses and port numbers so the third
and fourth layer are very important for
you to understand how network works if
you want to be a network pen tester then
IP IP layers and IP protocols and IP
types the header formats PCP UDP port
numbers and all the details inside that
and I'll repeat again 90 of hacking is
based on network so you need to learn
them you can learn from books there is
some good book I can recommend data
communication and networking from
photosyn that I personally used but you
can watch YouTube videos you can watch
courses knowledge repeat again 90
percent of hacking is based on network
so internet is networking the third
thing is Linux and shell programming if
you don't know majority of world's
servers are based out of Linux because
it's robust some examples for robust
Linux servers are rhel and send OS and
even after that the attacking machine
that most of the hackers use in the
world is based out of Linux because
Linux is open source Linux is robust
it's customizable so you know everything
about it and you need to be learning
shell programming because even if you
don't have any tools with guis you'll
need to learn how to use them on command
line it's very important because as a
hacker you might have seen that command
line window a black screen or a crane
text so that's very fancy right that is
what is terminal or a shell we need to
learn that to be cool just kidding
learning Linux is very easy you can
start from a beginner friendly OS like
Ubuntu it's very easy to learn you can
just explore and try things there learn
tools and then you can switch to a
hacker OS called Kali you might have
heard about it right many things so then
you can learn how to use tools because
it's made for penetration testers bipent
testers and there are many tools you can
you can Master you can learn the
techniques of hacking and it will be
very cool but first you need to make
sure that you're doing things right and
ethically and by shell programming in
Linux I mean Bash that's the current
standard of shell being used so there
are a lot of commands many simple
commands once you keep typing you'll
remember in your subconscious mind LS CD
PWD CP all of these commands will be
used in your daily basis and the next
thing is programming do we need to learn
programming many people ask me this
question is there a need I don't know
how to code I'm very weak in that but
I'll tell you if you opt for a offensive
job in a pen testing world you need to
learn how to program and how code is
written because in a corporate world
there is white box pen testing you get
access to the source code so you have to
extensively review the source code and
then find in that so there is no way out
eventually you'll need to learn it but
at the starting for a beginner I won't
say it's a big deal or a big headache to
conquer but you can keep it on hold for
some time just familiarize yourself with
cyber security concept and once you feel
you are ready to learn programming on
the side along the way then you can just
start it because eventually you'll need
to learn it at the end so why not start
early so it's a very simple concept
right how a software is made what is it
made of gold right so if you need to
hack a software you need to learn how it
is coded how it is written so you need
to learn to read code so you need to
learn many basic concepts of programming
like data types variables
conditioners Loops classes and objects
and these are enough so these are the
major Concepts that you need to learn in
basic programming and you can pick up
any programming language that you can
Master but you don't know which
programming language will come before
you to hack or test it can be anything
so you have to learn the basic concept
the center X are different in all the
languages but the basic concept is same
so these are the prerequisites that I
will recommend you to learn at the bare
minimum and these are very crucial so
once you get through all of them and do
brainstorming and keep everything in
mind and you've learned everything then
you can start go learn cyber security
from various sources because they are
very scattered and even then there is no
single course of cyber security there
are many domains many disciplines and
each of them have different things to
learn and topics and even here I have a
bare minimum concept to learn for you
all is the Avast top 10 so what is wasp
was in the foundation of web security
that is developed and designed for web
developers and security researchers to
make them aware about cyber attacks and
how they can secure themselves and every
three or four years they will release an
extensive list of top 10 vulnerabilities
or attacks that is the result of
consensus of all the issues and attacks
reported recently through statistics and
they have extensive Resorts Factory for
all of them including labs and tools and
they are all free so if you see the list
you will see some examples like Access
Control security misconfiguration secure
design ssrf I'm not going to take all
the names but for each attack type they
have their own descriptive documentation
they'll make you understand as a hacker
and also as a developer how you can see
how we can identify the issue in your
code and how you can fix them optimally
and even for all the issues there are
Labs that you can solve to practice them
and realize them in real world they have
many Labs including a wasp Juice Shop
Diva you can just set up them on your
local machine or just run a cloud
instance and then just practice them and
even they conduct conferences by the
name of wasp they also have their
YouTube Pages you can learn from them
and they have a lot of documentation
they have a two low ASP Zap for pen
testing just like burp Suite so they
have very good resources and I'll tell
you one thing that practice is the key
if you learn a concept day don't just
leave it like that the theory won't help
you in getting a job you need to
practice the concept each and every
attack issue framework volatility you
need to practice them on your own
Hands-On with your own Labs so I'll tell
you that you know already that how
technology changes drastically every day
so you need to get updated and be
proactive in learning new things this is
a complete practical field okay and then
there is another resource just like
wasps there is another resource called
Ford's trigger they have their own Labs
called Web Security Academy where you
can learn all the concepts of web
security and solve the labs online which
are free and also they have a tool
called burp Suite that's the most
popular tool that every hacker uses when
they want to pen test something so even
I use that even you will use that
everyone uses that and every Cyber
attack has an impact and a risk involved
in that there is a huge difference
between risk and impact that's where our
risk and compliance things come into
place the risk management there is a
different job file called GRC or
governance risk and compliance with many
other names but the concept is the same
that you find an issue but how to fix
that and how to fix the risk the risk is
associated to the business the risk and
compliance team will relate every risk
to the business impact or objective so
the basic goal of cyber security is to
identify and realize your risk and then
to contain it and reduces as much as
possible that's where hacker come in to
realize those risks and if I talk about
defensive jobs their job is to learn
digital forensics and incidents so they
need to learn how to do Incident
Management how to review the locks how
to use Siem tools and how to correlate
data so they'll have to find evidences
of all the attacks that recently
happened and continuously monitor the
network events and create alerts so that
they can respond to them so they have to
do a lot of Investigation correlation
and root cause analysis of the issue
once they find the route or the culprit
they'll try to reduce the risk and
prevent them from happening in the
future so likewise we have many domains
and each domain has its own deep
knowledge that you cannot claim that's
not possible you need to select a domain
of your choice you can only get by
research pastel study no College can
teach you that but I'll tell you one
more problem I told you everything that
you need to learn you learn everything
you gain all the skills you do a lot of
practice that you know that you know
everything that you can do and perform
those attacks but how will you tell the
HR how will the HR know so it's not just
about acquiring skills it's also about
proving your skills that's what happens
when you look for a job when you hunt a
job look for a good career the first
thing is to build your resume
professionally that's the short listing
criteria you won't even get to the
interviews if you don't take this
seriously so I'll tell you what all
things you'll need to add in your resume
so the first thing is degree
unfortunately you need to do a degree in
CS or it Branch because most companies
want that and my preference degree is
b-tech then BCA and then BSC but if you
are a maths student the p-tech is the
best option if you are an art student
then you don't have any choice you can
do BC or BSC if you are from any other
Branch like electrical mechanical civil
you haven't done bachelors in CS or it
then you can go for Masters you should
go for Masters but I won't say it's very
hard requirement or a very necessary
thing to do I didn't do Masters myself
but if you want you can do that it will
be a good option for a job if you're
getting good placements in that college
but I'll tell you that the degree is the
only thing that we require we don't care
about anything else and how you do it
you just need that certificate so you
can do private programs distant learning
anything doesn't matter the second thing
is projects they are very important as a
fresher specially because you don't have
any work experience so you need to do
something apart from your learning so
whatever you learned whatever skills you
gained you should apply them somewhere
to prove it like that's the point so you
can apply our cyber security skills with
any other domain like AI Cloud security
blockchain web3 include anything combine
them and create a good project with many
project ideas that I can give you and
then you need to open source that
because you need to show the employer
because they will demand and require
your link that they can verify
themselves because there are many false
alarms out there and I've already told
you how you can do projects in cyber
security that simply learn internship
from mpci from that advanced executive
program will give you four projects
that's all you need that's all you need
to put so you can put that link in your
resume along with your LinkedIn that's
equally important and the next thing is
certifications and I'll tell you that if
you do a certification and you don't
need to do a master's degree at all it's
not required do some good certifications
because they teach you a skill in a
particular niche in deep in a shorter
time so it won't take you two years it
will just take you one month two months
three months or maximum six months if
you are good enough and there are many
certifications right now in the market
that you can choose but for India for an
HR I think ceh is the most basic
certification that they look because
they all know that but skill wise eh is
not good it's just a theory Examination
for practical skills for actual skill
development you should give oscp because
HR loves it and also you'll get a better
job with a better salary and a better
company with oscp because it's more
skillful and more better than ceh holder
and also the problem is with oacp is the
price that's why not many people take it
it's more costly but if you want to be
cheaper and gain some practical skills
too you can do e-learn certifications
like ejpt ecppt or eccpd you can correct
me Ewa PTX those are very practical and
very good certifications not on the
level of oscp very close to them but
still they are cheaper so it's a good
deal there are more certifications that
are more relevant in outside countries
like Security Plus pen Test Plus crtp so
that you can do that if you want to plan
for some foreign countries or foreign
jobs so likewise two three
certifications are more than enough and
now comes work experience the internship
I've already told you how to get an
internship just go to the simply lens
program and you will get it just enroll
there so that's not a problem for you
but if you want extra internships you'll
go to the LinkedIn create an account
today you'll need to be actively
involved in LinkedIn and don't use any
other social media more than LinkedIn
because it's going to help you in your
job search the most so connect with
people do an internship at least three
months or maybe six months it will gain
you a good experience on how work is
done in an industry and then even that
company itself can give you a job offer
called PPO and you can join with a good
package or a salary so now your resume
is strong enough you can actively look
for jobs and that too it will be the
same in LinkedIn so you need to build as
much connections as possible with good
people working in a good company in your
desired cyber security domain connect
with HRS and approach them talk to them
personally share your resume be
professional be polite be kind and make
sure that you reveal a sense of passion
inside you and building a good Network
in LinkedIn helps a lot you will get a
lot of referrals if possible if you
don't know what referral is is you can
just get into a company with the trust
of another person that's already working
in that company and getting a referral
makes your job hunt much easier you land
a job much easier because you'll get
interviews and even if you make some
mistakes in your interviews it will be a
trust Factor they will be tolerable and
they'll select you and for a job hunt I
have seen people talking to me coming
back saying that they are not getting a
job they've tried hard enough but when I
ask them how many companies you have
applied on they say only 5 or 10 that
doesn't make sense you need to apply at
least 50 to 100 companies because the
average reward rate is 10 so if you
apply in 50 companies you will get reply
from five of them so that's the rate and
keep that in mind try hard as you can so
when your resume is shortlisted you'll
have three to four technical rounds with
a managerial round these are the average
figures and if you are applying for an
offensive job like a pen tester you'll
get you'll expect OAS top 10 and code
review questions definitely and scenario
based questions are a very common and
good companies today because they'll
have to test you on a hypothetical
situation how you handle the situation
what is the decision-making approach and
how you solve the problems in very
stressful environment how you can work
under stress and don't even lose your
composure and calm in those situations
so the technical skills are not enough
you need to have some soft skills like
communication skills listening skills
decision making skills and always have a
growth mindset I'll tell you one simple
key to getting a job in cyber security
is to understand the risk of your assets
and learn how to contain them and adapt
to the ever evolving and changing threat
landscape cyber security is an Ever
evolving field its scope is not gonna
get declined anytime soon it will just
keep improving so the only problem with
people is that they don't learn
consistently so you need to learn
consistently and be aware of all the
technological updates around you and you
should be good so all the best for your
next cyber security job if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered the topics that we are going to
discuss in this video are what exactly
hacking is the types of hackers the
classifications what is ethical hacking
the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker the process that is
utilized by ethical hackers in their
daily activities and then lastly we are
going to discuss cryptography so let's
talk about hacking and what exactly
hacking is hacking refers to exploiting
weaknesses in a computer network work to
obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some keywords that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you are exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a Security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that you
are not allowed to do and when you say a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
it's basically a person with malicious
intent trying to gain access to a system
or a resource that they are not
authorized to access in the first place
how do they do it they find the
vulnerability that is a weakness or a
flaw and then they misuse it to gain
access to that particular Network so
here in the diagram you can see that a
send window on the left hand side is
trying to send some data to the receiver
on the right hand side the hacker would
try to gain unauthorized access to the
transmission that is being sent and
would try to capture the data packets
and read the secrets within let's look
at a business case scenario into hacking
now there is an organization everybody
is going around their own business when
they realize that their systems may have
been compromised now they're trying to
look at the customer data to ensure that
that has not been compromised under
trying to assure you the customers
however they do realize that some
customer data has been lost and even
their company reports have been modified
as well now this is the scenario where
there have been some security controls
in place and those controls have been
identified they realized that there is
an attack that has happened and based on
that attack they have realized that the
data has now been compromised and the
records have been modified by the hacker
which means that the data is no longer
trustworthy and thus cannot be used by
the business for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or gets connected to the
organization demanding your ransom for
the data to be replaced to be taken back
into the original state where it was
trusted and thus the organization can
utilize it for business transactions the
organization has probably no backup so
they decide that they want to pay the
lump sum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues at as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to Leverage The misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and make these ransomware demands so the
company then wants to figure out even if
having a security system in place how
was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus one of the employees comes
up with a brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities in the network to
proactively search for any flaws that
have been left behind so that they can
plug those flaws and nobody can misuse
them thus they figure out that they want
to hire an ethical hacker who would help
them identify the security posture of
the organization identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those flaws so that in future
scenarios these scenarios will not
happen so before we go into an ethical
hacker let's understand what are the
types of hackers so what are the types
of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person who is very Adept with
computers they have good programming
skills they understand how operating
system works they understand how
networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws to get a outcome which would
be detrimental to the health of the
organization so there's six type of
hackers that have been identified black
hat hackers white hat hackers gray hat
script kitties nation's sponsored
hackers and a hack toist so black hat
hackers are patients basically uh the
malicious hackers who have malicious
intent and have criminalistic Tendencies
they want to harm the organization by
hacking into their infrastructure by
destroying their infrastructure by
destroying their data so that they can
gain from it from a monetary perspective
these guys are also known as crackers
the main aspect of these people are that
they have malicious intent they try to
do unauthorized activities and they try
it for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
Identity or they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a white ad hacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who's an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security posture so
these uh these kind of Security Experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks gray hat hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kiddies are people uh who are
technically not much aware about what
hacking is they rely on existing tools
and have been created by other hackers
they have no technical knowledge of what
they're doing it's just a hit or miss
for them so they just get their hands on
a tool they try to execute those tools
if the hack works it works otherwise it
doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or uh just uh people
who with malicious intent who just want
to have some fun or trying to impress
people around then we have the nation or
the state sponsored hackers as the name
suggests these hackers are sponsored by
their government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers enrolled in
their pay on on their organizations to
spy on their enemies to spy on various
countries and try to figure out uh the
aspirations of those countries so this
is basically a spying activity where you
are technically trying to get access to
other countries resources and then try
to spy on them to figure out what their
activities have been or what their
future plans have been and then we have
the hacktivists who is an individual who
has a political agenda to promote and
they promote it by doing hacking so
these guys what is the difference
between a black hat hacker and a
hacktivist the black hat hacker may try
to hide their identity a hacktivist will
claim responsibility of what they have
done so for them it's a political agenda
a political cause and they will try to
hack various organizations to promote
their cause they would probably do this
by defacing the website and posting the
messages that they want to promote on
these websites so what exactly is
ethical hacking then we have discussed
the types of hackers we have identified
a malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what they
are allowed to do and what they are not
allowed to do and the ethical hackers
would function within those Scopes would
try to execute those at test scenarios
where they would be able to identify
those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhead hackers do however
the main difference here is that these
guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again an ethical hacker
is a highly intelligent Highly Educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
Adept at Computing they understand the
architecture they understand how various
components in a computer work they can
troubleshoot those components and they
can basically be very good with
programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want ethical hacker
to be a good developer of applications
we want them to understand programming
in such a way that they can create
scripts they can write their own short
programs like viruses worms Trojans or
exploits which would help them achieve
the objective that they have set out for
so here you can see the ethical hacker
there are individuals who perform a
security assessment of the companies
with the permission of concerned
authorities so what is a security
assessment a security assessment is
finding out the exact security posture
of the organization by identifying what
security controls are in place how
they've been configured and if there are
any gaps in the configurations
themselves so an organization will hire
a ethical hacker they would give the
ethical hacker the information about
what information is or what security
controls what firewalls what idss ipss
intrusion detection or intrusion
prevention systems anti-virus is already
in place and then they will ask the
ethical hacker to figure out a way to
bypass these mechanisms and see if they
can still hack the organization what is
the need of an ethical hacker the need
of an ethical hacker is proactive of
security the ethical hacker would
identify all the existing flaws in an
organization and try to resolve those
laws to help secure the organization
from black hat hackers so ethical
hackers would prevent Hackers from
cracking into an organization's Network
by securing the organization by
improving on their security on a
periodic basis and they would also try
to identify system vulnerabilities
Network vulnerabilities or application
Level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or resolving them so that
they cannot be misused by other hackers
they would also analyze and enhance an
organization's security policies now
what are policies policies are basically
documents that have been created by an
organization of rules that all the
employees need to follow to ensure that
the security of an organization is
maintained for example a password policy
a password policy would help users in an
organization to adhere to the standards
the organization has identified for a
password complexity T for example a
password when a user is creating them
should adhere to standards where they
are using random words they are they
contain the alphabet A through Z
uppercase and low case 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters and they
are randomized so that the password
becomes much more stronger to prevent
from Brute Force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at this point in
time they would try to test the strength
of the passwords to see if Brute Force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they would ensure that
all the employees are following the
policies and all the passwords are as
secured as the policies want them to be
if there are any gaps in the policies or
the implementation of the policy it is
the ethical Hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and warn the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they will try to protect it by from
falling into the Hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as Windows Linux Unix and
Mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security Center of Windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with Linux and Mac
softwares operating systems so we need
to know how we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as an
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time there should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
PHP python Ruby HTML for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for and ethical
hackers should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're an application security
you are in network security or you're in
host based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a local area network like a land
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the OSI model we should
know which protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the TCP model
and how OSI model can be mapped to the
TCP model we should understand how TCP
and UDP work how how each and every
protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analyze and
understand any network based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should know where those
vulnerabilities would lie what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
Implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause a
new harm to any of the employees or any
of the third party clients that they are
dealing with so the ethical hacker
should be aware of what security laws
are before they Implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming it's good to have
a certification in PHP pull python Ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize in their testing scenarios to be
honest there are hundreds of tools out
there what you see on the screen as just
a few examples of them uh nessus is a
vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within
operating systems within networks so
they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified and
the scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist on the host or the
operating system or on the network
similarly there would be application
scanners like acunetics or Arachne that
would help you scan applications and
identify flaws within those applications
as well now all of these are automated
tools the essence of ethical hacker is
when these tools churn out the reports
the ethical hacker can understand these
reports analyze them identify the flaws
and then craft their own exploits or use
existing exploits in a particular manner
so that they can get access or they can
bypass their access or security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
Metasploit you see that that Big M there
on the right hand side that M logo is
for a tool called Metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where Metasploit helps us do that
Wireshark would be used in the
background while we are doing both the
activities using nessus or Metasploit to
keep a track of what packets are being
sent and by received on the network
which will help us analyze those packets
so whenever I run a necess scanner I
would run a Wireshark in the background
it will capture the data packets and I
can go through those data packets and
analyze that data package to identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when I try to attack a machine
using exploit on Metasploit I will keep
on Wireshark running in the background
to capture the data package that have
been sent and the responses that I've
received from the victim so that I can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and basically
it will also give me a validation of
proof of the activity that has happened
nmap is another automated tool that
allows me to scan for open ports and
protocols so why would I use nmap
because Pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect to a
web browser but we automatically connect
to Port 80 using HTTP and Port 443 is
using https so if I'm connecting to a
web server using https it is safe to
assume that Port 443 on the web server
is open to accept those kind actions
similarly there would be other services
that may be left open on the web server
because nobody thought about configuring
it or they misconfigured the web server
and they left unwanted Services running
so nmap will allow me to scan those
ports and services and allow me to
understand what services are being
offered on that server so then I can
start analyzing that server identify
those flaws within those services and
then try to attack them if the
application that I'm analyzing is
connected to a database and I want to do
a SQL injection attack or if I if nessus
tells me that there is a SQL injection
attack that may be possible on that
particular application I can use an
automated tool called SQL map or SQL map
that would allow me to automatically
craft all the queries that are required
for a SQL injection attack and help me
do that attack at the same time so here
I do not have to manually create my own
queries uh the SQL map tool would
automatically create them for me what I
would do is I would use Nexus to
identify that particular flaw if nessus
reports that flaw I will would then go
use the tool SQL map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when I fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management providing them
feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that we would follow so there are six
steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hackers perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a Windows
based server and I use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a Linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so I need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase I want to
identify all of that information once I
have that information done I'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap I would run
a vulnerability scanner the nasus
vulnerabilities scanner we talked about
or akinetics for applications and then I
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once I have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that I may have found
during the scanning phase once I have
gained my access I want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody we
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist existing or
somebody changed the password that we I
may have cracked thus I no longer have
access so what do I do to maintain my
access I installed Trojans or backdoor
entries to those systems using which I
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where I maintain my access I have hacked
them now I want to maintain my access so
I install a software which would give me
a backdoor entry to that device no
matter what once I have done this I want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that I've been doing for example
installing a Trojan a Trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victims machine so I want to hide
that if I have access data stores if I
have modified data I want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline does my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason I'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot raise the
compromise back to me so I would be
deleting references of any of the IP
addresses or Mac addresses that I may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where I will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once I
take off those traces the victim would
not be any wiser of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
they were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or or the expected output
of that attack I'll create a report
which would give a detailed analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this
recognizance is where you're going to
use hiking tools like nmap HP to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again nmap next pose these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the Metasploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install backdoors
you can use meta square at the same time
you can craft your own scripts to create
Trojan and install it on the victim's
machine once you have achieved that
clearing tracks is where you're going to
clear all evidences of your activity so
that you do not get caught or the victim
doesn't even realize that they have been
hacked and once you have done all of
this we are going to create reports that
are going to be submitted to the
management to help them understand the
current security evaluation of their
organization so now let's see how we can
hack using social engineering now what
is social engineering social engineering
is the art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen phishing activity what is
phishing we receive a lot of frequents
on a regular basis we have always
received those emails where we have won
a lottery of a few million dollars but
we have never realized that we didn't
purchase a lot to win a lottery in the
first place we have always had those
Nigerian frauds where a prince died in
some South African country and you out
of 7 billion people on the planet have
been identified where they want to
transfer a few hundred million dollars
through your account and they want to
give you 50 of that money in return as
thank you so some very basic attacks
where you go on to websites and there's
a banner flashing at you saying
congratulations you're the one millionth
visitor to this website click here to
claim your price all of these are social
engineering attacks phishing attacks
fake websites fake Communications being
sent out to users to prey on their
gullibility most of humans always have
that dream of striking it rich winning a
huge Lottery once and for all and living
their life lavishly ever after but sadly
in the real world that's not that
doesn't happen that often and if you're
receiving those meals it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotion
machines do not try pleading with the
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social engineering attack
where you can plead with them saying if
I do not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
cool that you attended you probably have
that listed on your LinkedIn profile
where a person can just go in there and
see your academic qualifications and
identify the school that you were in
right similarly it might also be a
question what was your mother's maiden
name that's a very good attack and
that's uh I mean if a person can
interact with you let's say they are
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is open
a generic attack whoever Falls victim
will fall victim so if I just throw
around a few USBS in the parking lot
obviously with Trojans implemented on
them some people who are curious or who
are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in there those pen drives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine then exploiting human
greed we just talked about the Nigerian
frauds and the lotteries those kind of
attacks the fake money making gimmicks
now basically this is where you Prey
Upon the person's agreed kicking in and
they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the you end user using this same key
would then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer would once made into
unreadable format would look like eqor
xvgt for an end user it wouldn't make
any sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer and then
understand the meaning of that word so
this is just a substitution Cipher that
has been shown on the screen so what is
the alphabet the key is alphabet plus
three so C plus three alphabets that
becomes e o becomes q m becomes o so the
key that is utilized to scramble the
data is the character that you are at
the third character from there would be
the corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponding
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out uh or you
want to decrypt that data now as ethical
hacker you wouldn't be for paying a
ransom to the hacker would you so it is
now your prerogative of how you're going
to work around and how you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher to decrypt that
message and see what's within it right
decryption without the use of a secret
key that is known as a crypt analysis
Crypt analysis is the reversing of an
algorithm to figure out what the
decryption was without using a key so
Crypt analysis can be done using various
formats the first one is a Brute Force
attack second is a dictionary attack
third one is a rainbow table attack a
Brute Force attack is trying every
combination permutation and combination
of the key to figure out what the key
was it is 100 successful but may take a
lot of time a dictionary attack is where
you have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out the similarities between between the
text that you have and the encrypted
data that you wanted to decrypt in the
first place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tant amount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the ciphertext
is compared with another Cipher text you
find out similarities and then you try
to work a reverse engineer your way
accordingly so let's have a quick demo
on cryptography before we end this
session so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on our website
called spammy.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
I say I want to encode a message I turn
a short message into spam so what this
does is you want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one and it will convert that into
a spam mail you send it across so
whoever is reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if I want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is ASD at the right
one two three four and I want to send
this out to people or to one of my
colleagues but I want to send it out in
a secret manner so that others are not
aware of this so when I press on encode
what the algorithm would do is it will
convert this message into a spam mail so
my message hi this is a secret message
the password is at the rate1234 or ASG
at the rate one two three four gets
converted into this now if you read it
dear e-commerce professional this letter
was specially selected to be sent to you
this doesn't make sense there is nowhere
or no reference to the actual message
that I've already sent so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is Spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open up a new browser and I'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time I am going to click on decode
when I click on decode and going to
paste the message that I have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if I decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we paste the message in the decode
Factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the Google Chrome
browser and in the Firefox browser we
decoded similarly if I want to protect
these kind of messages there is an
aspenencrypt.com website where let's say
we use text encryption and I want to
encrypt the same message this is a
secret message the password is ASD at
the rate1234 and then I give it the
password to protect this message let's
say the word password and I use the
cipher to scramble this by using let's
say AES which is the strongest Cipher
right now and I say encrypt so this is
what the encryption would look like and
basically if I don't have the password
over here if I decrypt it you would see
that there it has occurred and if I type
in the password over here and then
decrypt it it will be able to convert
that back into the unscrambled text and
it will give me what the original
message was this is a secret message the
password is ASD at the rate one two
three four so if I want to keep my data
secure from hackers I want to scramble
it in such a way that they would not be
able to crack it or it would be very
difficult from for them to crack it and
this is one of the first mechanisms that
would be recommended by any ethical
hacker if you want to kick start your
career as a cyber security professional
in six months then try giving a show to
Simply learns Caltech cyber security
Bootcamp The Bootcamp link is mentioned
in the description box that will
navigate you to the Boot Camp Page where
you can find a complete overview of the
boot camp being offered and now let's
take a minute to hear from my Learners
who've experienced massive success in
their careers by opting out for these
courses now we'll see the job roles in
ethical hacking field so starting with
like there are several job roles in
ethical hacking such as here's an
elaboration on each job role in ethical
hacking and
we'll see some of the major ethical
hacker job roles so starting with
ethical hacker so an ethical hacker is a
skilled professional who legally
attempts to penetrate computer system
and networks to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses they use their knowledge
to strengthen the security
infrastructure and protect against cyber
threats and the next is network security
engineer network security Engineers
specialize in securing and maintaining
computer networks within an organization
they Implement and manage security
measures such as firewalls inclusion
detection systems and virtual private
networks that is vpns to protect
sensitive data then we have cyber
security analyst so cyber security
analyst Monitor and analyze systems for
potential security breaches or incidents
they investigate threats develop
security protocols and Implement
measures to protect against attacks the
next is penetration tester penetration
testers also known as ethical hackers
simulate real world attacks to identify
vulnerabilities in computer systems
networks and applications they conduct
thorough assessments and provide
recommendations for improving security
the next is information security manager
information security managers are
responsible for overseeing an
organizations overall security strategy
and ensuring the protection of sensitive
data they develop and Implement security
policies many security teams and handle
incident response and the next is cyber
security engineer so cyber security
Engineers design and Implement security
systems including firewalls encryption
protocols and intrusion detection
systems do you also conduct risk
assessments and perform security audits
to maintain a security environment and
the next is security consultant Security
Consultants provide expert advice and
guidance on security strategies and
solutions the assess vulnerabilities
develop security plans and assist
organizations in improving their overall
security posture in the United States
these requirements are very high and
this was all for this tutorial did you
know that in August this year Google
openly admitted that some of its Gmail
accounts for hackband Iranian group
fortunately the event was isolated and
was taken care of but rarely our
security breaches this easy to stop with
more and more data moving to the cloud
the prospects of hacks like these have
grown in the past decade exponentially
consequently organizations have now
discovered the need to secure the
digital infrastructure against various
attack vectors fueling the need for
ethical hackers in the IT industry see
today's video is all about how you can
learn the ins and outs of hacking and
cyber security irrespective of your
learning background so welcome to our
video on how to become an ethical hacker
by simple learn before we get started
ensure you are subscribed to the channel
so you always stay updated with the
latest Technologies and Trends let's
first clear the air on an ethical
Hacker's role the term hacking has
inherently negative connotations however
this will only be applicable until the
duty of an ethical hacker is properly
understood ethical hackers are the good
people in the hacking field wearing the
white hat so what exactly is the
responsibility of an ethical hacker
instead of utilizing the extensive
computer expertise for criminal purposes
ethical hackers find gaps in data and
computer security for businesses and
organizations worldwide to defend
themselves against hackers with less
than noble intentions ethical hacking is
a subcategory of cyber security that
involves lawfully breaking a system
security mechanisms in order to discover
possible threats and data leaks on the
network ethical hackers can work for
cooperation as independent Freelancers
in-house security staff for its website
or its applications or as simulated
offensive cyber Security Professionals
as well
all of these careers need knowledge of
current attack methodologies and tools
albeit the in-house expert may need to
be knowledgeable about a single kind of
software or digital asset but how can
you hone your ethical hacking skills
let's take a look at few steps one can
take while starting a career in this
field the first step is getting
comfortable with Linux there are
operating systems catered specifically
to ethical hackers like Kali Linux and
parrot security both are based on Linux
derivatives and have a plethora of tools
to make your hacking workflow easy and
relatively stress-free the better worst
you are with Linux and its terminal the
quicker you can achieve things when
hacking the next would be to master the
mother of all programming languages
which is the C programming language
since Linux and a lot of back-end code
are written in C having a strong hand
over this programming language is very
important it's always helpful to learn a
couple more relevant languages like
python or JavaScript which will help you
dissect giant pieces of server code like
button
remaining Anonymous is vital in the
hacking sphere since giving a malicious
actor news of your existence on a Target
Network can cause him then to flee or
attack your device instead the usage of
Mac address randomizers and proxy chains
is highly beneficial and recommended
when monitoring networks for criminal
activity and speaking of proxies ethical
hackers must understand networking
fundamentals and exactly how they are
established learning about various
networks and protocols might help you
exploit flaws an ethical hacker with an
extensive understanding of networking
tools such as Wireshark nmap and others
can overcome field incidents relatively
unscaled the first skill in our list is
traversing the dark web using the famous
store browser most of the internet is
hidden behind the Tor networks and
getting a closer look at the people who
often are at the Forefront of the
hacking industry in the dark web
directly can help you familiarize
yourself with a certain domain Secrets
while keeping you updated with the
latest happenings in the cyber crime
World A major advantage that can tip the
skills in the framework of an ethical
hacker is the knowledge of crypto or
encryption encryption is used in various
elements of information security
including authentication data Integrity
anonymity and others passwords and other
sensitive information are always
encrypted on our Network hacker must
understand how to recognize and break
these encryption standards exploring
vulnerabilities make you a better
ethical hacker simply keeps you aware
the security measures that are kept in
place as industry standards while
handing you the most advanced
penetration testing tools on the market
learning how to scan networks and
systems for vulnerabilities that might
result in a security breach ethical
hackers may also attempt to write
vulnerabilities to explore the system in
question as a final tip join forums for
conversations with other hackers
worldwide to trade share expertise and
collaborate Discord ready Telegram and
other platforms all have communities
where you can join and collaborate with
fellow Learners to broaden your learning
Spectrum Natalie understands some basic
skills ethical hackers need to excel in
this domain let us look at the roadmap
one can follow to get started many
ethical hackers begin their careers by
studying computer science you can also
acquire an A plus certification from com
Tia by appearing for and passing to
additional tests these tests
individual's understanding of PC
components and their ability to
disassemble and reassemble a PC however
before advancing in your profession you
must gather experience and obtain on
network Plus or a ccns certification the
network plus certification certifies
fundamental Network expertise such as
Network Administration maintenance
deployment and troubleshooting the CCNA
certification guarantees the same skills
and stripes for foundation level
proficiency once qualified you can
advance to the next level of your career
in network support you'll be responsible
for monitoring and upgrading installing
security software and testing for
vulnerabilities you will obtain
expertise in network security and your
goal should be offered as a position as
a network engineer as a network engineer
you will build and plan networks rather
than simply maintain them your focus
should now be on the security part of
your journey to becoming an ethical
hacker this is the time to focus on
earning a security certifications such
as Security Plus or cisp the US
Department of Defense has approved the
Security Plus accredition which covers
testing on critical areas such as Access
Control identity authentication and
cryptography the cissp certification is
a worldwide recognized security
acquisition that validates the expertise
of risk management Cloud technology and
application development The Next Step
would be to start working in the
information security Division and
information security analyst study
systems and network security engages
with security breaches and strives to
implement Security Solutions for this
profession you should focus on
penetration testing to gain Hands-On
experiences some of the most essential
tools of the trade getting the certified
ethical hacker or the CES certification
should be your top priority the training
will teach you all you must understand
to become a productive and ethical
hacker you will be engaged in a Hands-On
environment where you will be guided
through breaking into a network and
finding any security flaws after
obtaining this certification you can
begin marketing yourself as a
professional ethical hacker we have
already covered some skills one needs to
learn when starting their Journey
however an ethical hacker has certain
rules and responsibilities that must be
carried out ridiculously the first of
which is threat modeling threat modeling
is optimizing network security by
identifying vulnerabilities and
determining counter measures for
avoiding or reducing an attack's impact
on the system a threat is a real or
projected negative incident jeopardizing
the organization's assets the role of an
ethical hacker is to give a thorough
assessment of potentially harmful
assaults and their potential
consequences they can also conduct
information security audits or a
risk-based evaluation of a company
security
these regular exercises assess
Securities Readiness identify it system
weaknesses and offer strategies for
reducing future attack threads they also
assess how successfully security related
policies are implemented resulting in a
report that includes discovered flaws
and appropriate Solutions ethical
writers must be able to collect data
detect vulnerabilities and coordinate
risks to create clear and unambiguous
professional reports these evaluations
are frequently used to justify
finalizing security asset expenditures
the market for trained ethical hackers
has never been this expensive according
to various surveys the job outlet for
ethical hackers and information security
analysts is supposed to grow by 33
within 2020 and 2030. companies like IBM
Google and Microsoft are always on the
lookout for trained cyber security
Personnel in this climate of data
breaches and security vulnerabilities we
hope this video has cleared some doubts
regarding where to start and what to
learn during this journey we want to
understand what is penetration testing
now for penetration testing there is a
phase called vulnerability assessment
that happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing about running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration tests this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
information systems so you have
identified that law maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be a buffer over a warrant flaw or
it could be a simple password tracking
attempt your idea is to create those
tools create those attacks and try to
penetrate into those areas where
security is weak uh the essence of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks should be anything
like a phishing attack a password
cracking attack a denial of service
attack or any other vulnerabilities that
you have identified during a
vulnerability scan so what is Kali Linux
and why is it used Kali Linux is an
operating system often used by hackers
and ethical hackers both because of the
tool sets that the operating system
contains it is Operating System created
by professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a dbn based operating system
with Advanced penetration testing and
security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus or tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of that tax man in the
middle attack sniffing password cracking
any of these attacks would be possible
with all the tools available you just
need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said 100 of hundreds of tools
that are used for various information
security tasks like computer forensics
reverse engineering information finding
even getting access to different
machines and then creating viruses worms
Trojans anything that you will 600 plus
tools in the Kali liners operating
system there are periodic updates that
are given out to the operating system as
well it is open source that means it is
free to utilize you can even have the
source code you can modify it if you
want to test customizations available
for all the tools you can download third
party tools and install them if you want
there's a wide support for wireless
network cards multiple languages are
being supported at the time at the same
time as well and you can create a lot of
attacking scripts you can create a
tracking tools and you can write your
own exploits as well on Kali Linux so
this all all in all helps you create a
very robust system where you can create
your own tags and then launch them
against unsuspecting victims now that is
illegal so as for ethical is concerned
once you have authorization you're going
to identify which tools to be utilize
you're going to get the appropriate
permissions and only then are you going
to attempt those attacks let's talk
about the phases of penetration testing
now there are five different phases the
first one is the recognizance phase also
known as the information gathering phase
this is the most important phase for any
hacker this is where the hacker or the
ethical hacker if you will will gather
as much information about the target's
victim or vice versa the victim right so
once you have that information you would
then be able to identify what tool sets
to include and how to attack the victim
for example you want to find out the IP
addresses the domains sub domains the
network architecture is being utilized
you want to identify operating systems
that are being utilized the network IP
ranges that are being utilized and so on
so forth you might want to identify
employees within an organization for
social engineering attacks in the future
email addresses telephone numbers
anything and everything that will help
you validate and give you information
about the target is something that you
want to do in the recognizance phase at
this point in time we are not going to
question whether whatever information we
are getting is useful or not only time
will tell depending on the various
attacks that we will be building up
later on this becomes your Baseline this
becomes your database with all the
information about the victim so that you
can come back from later stages back to
the reconnaissance phase to look at the
information that you have gathered and
then you can fine tune your attacks once
you have done that you are going to then
start the scanning phase based on the
information that you have gathered you
are going to identify live machines
within a network once you've identified
the live machines you'll scan them for
open ports protocols and procedures any
processes that are running and then we
were going to identify vulnerabilities
Within These processors and Within These
open ports so in the scanning phase uh
why do we need to find live machines
because we want to find out the machines
that have booted up have an operating
system and are running on the network if
an OP machine is not available on the
network or is in a shutdown mode that
machine cannot be hacked through a
technical attack then it would be a
physical attack where you physically go
to the machine and then do whatever you
want to do with it for a technical
attack you will have to identify the
machines that have booted up then you're
going to scan the open ports because
that's going to be your entry point and
on the port would be a service that is
running so you scan the service as well
identify the version of the service and
then do a vulnerability scan to identify
if there any vulnerabilities on those
services that are running and then based
on all of this information we are going
to develop our attacks as we go on so
once we have this we go on to the
gaining access phase where we are going
to attack and try to get access to our
victims machines could be a social
engineering attack based on the
information gathering we have done in
the technical assessment and scanning
phase if you have identified a
vulnerability we are going to identify a
relevant exploit and then use that
exploit to try to gain access or we
might just craft a Trojan and try to
execute that Trojan on the victim's
machine to check if we can get access
through that particular manner once we
have the access it could be even a
simple password cracking attack which we
have been able to accomplish and we have
cracked the password of the person and
now we have gained access to that
person's computer right but these
attacks would be temporary for example
we have cracked a password somebody
changes the password every 30 days after
that period our attack would be useless
if a Trojan is executed we get a
connection to that machine for once but
then how do we get get a repeated
connection over and over again if you
want to reconnect to that machine so
that's where we come into the
maintaining access phase where we
install root kits key loggers sniffers
and things like that where we could get
a backdoor entry to the victim's machine
if we have already been successfully
installed at Trojan we would want to add
the torsion to the startup menu so that
every time the operating system starts
the Trojan gets automatically executed
and thus we maintain the back door entry
to that victim's machine once we have
done all of this all these activities
are going to leave a trace in the
victim's machine so if you install a
Trojan a Trojan being an application
would create directories and files a
virus would be destructive in nature if
you are executing a script it will leave
some logs behind if we even log in
through the cracked password that we
have it will create a login entry and
for that particular timestamp along with
the IP address that we utilized in the
covering tracks we are essentially
trying to avoid detection by deleting
traces of our activity that means that
we need to identify where logs have been
stored we need to address those logs and
we need to delete them or modify them in
such a way that our app activity is not
traceable so these are the five main
phases of a penetration test gather as
much information as you can scan for
machines ports protocols and services
running on the victim's device try to
gain access by password cracking
inclusions exploits for the
vulnerabilities if any maintain that
access by installing further software
which will allow you to get back to our
access to that particular system and
then try to cover your tracks by
deleting all traces of your activity
once successful the victim will have no
idea and you have a back door entry and
you can monitor the victim to the extent
that you want now in a ethical hackers
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
that tax we've got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
manners first is the Black Box test the
Black Box test is where no information
is given to the ethical hacker about the
ID infrastructure so they have no idea
what it is they start right from the
first phase of the information gathering
gather as much information they can and
based on the gathered information they
try to create and launch attacks to see
if they are going to be successful now
not only does it test the knowledge of
the penetration tester it would also
test the security implementations that
the organization has done to see whether
they can identify the attack and prevent
it in the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the ID infrastructure is
given think of it from a employee's
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges like an administrator but as
just a regular employee does that means
that they were limited access within the
organization based on which they get
some knowledge of the IIT infrastructure
so this is an attempt of an Insider uh
simulation attack where a regular user
may want to try to misuse the access
that they've been given and then try to
gather information or try to gain access
to other devices which they are not
authorized to the third test is white
box where there's full knowledge of the
ID infrastructure that has been given so
this is again a simulation of an Insider
attack a malicious Insider if you will
but at this point in time the person has
complete knowledge of the infrastructure
could be in an administrative position
and then they are trying to leverage
their access to see if they can get
information or they can compromise any
stock any of the data so the three
attacks would be the first one black box
where we are simulating external threat
a hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to gain access the
gray box is an Insider threat where
there is a regular employee who is
trying to get access to infrastructure
that they are not what race for and in
the third order is a white box audit
where there's an administrator who has
all the leverage all the access and the
visibility within the infrastructure and
then they are trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test thus compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of the user so first and
foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in the network all of these
are devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some
vulnerabilities behind if V as ethical
hackers are able to identify these flaws
these misconfigurations these
vulnerabilities we could then try to
exploit them and try to gain access to
the network and devices within that
Network by getting access to the network
in the first place then we have the web
applications web applications are
nothing but softwares that are developed
over or deployed over a web server and
are made available over the intranet or
the internet for example uh websites
that we visit or web applications like
Facebook if you will right so if these
applications have vulnerabilities within
them we then try to attack the web-based
applications and thus try to bypass
authentication or get access to database
or try to leak information through those
applications if not then we try to
attack the client side now web
application is at the server level and
is hosted by the deployer so that's at
the server side the client side is where
we as users are using a computer with a
browser and trying to interact with the
web application now the browser and the
operating system that we are utilizing
would have its own vulnerabilities thus
identifying a client-side availability
and then exploiting it to either either
hack the client or then piggyback on the
client's connection and try to get
access to the server so either you could
attack the network the application or
the client side itself or you could
attack wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphones
tablets phablets all of those connected
to them if you are able to access any of
these devices to the wireless it would
help you gain access to other devices on
the wireless as well and then social
engineering so this is where you're
trying to attack humans you are tracking
an employee of a corporation to reveal
some confidential information knowingly
or unknowingly by tricking them with the
fake mails or fake websites or malicious
emails that you have sent to them which
they have failed to recognize as
malicious and they click on it thus
getting victimized social engineering
attacks are always successful because of
the gullibility of humans empathy
sympathy humans basically have emotions
emotions can be toyed with and then
taken advantage of if the person is not
careful enough for example the most
common social engineering attack that we
see is the Nigerian fraud where we
receive an email that someone somewhere
has died and has left a huge estate
behind a few hundred million dollars and
we have been identified as the person
through whom they want to transfer the
money to a foreign land to save on taxes
what are the chances of that happening
on a daily basis right how many princes
are there so that's something that we do
not verify it's just the I guess the
greed if you will of striking it rich
quickly that makes cases believe these
kind of emails we have also received
emails of lottery tickets that we have
won over a period of time without even
having bought a lottery ticket so if you
haven't bought one what did you win but
we don't ask these questions we just get
excited about the amount of money that
we have won and then we try to bet on
our luck and try to see if that email is
going to fructify or is it just under
the scam so social engineering attacks
are time a dozen these days and we need
to be very careful on what we trust on
the internet let's look at the
penetration testing tools there are
hundreds and thousands of tools out
there most of these have been concised
and collected together and hosted on a
operating system known as Kali Linux
that we have talked about earlier now
the predecessor to Kali Linux was
backtrack backtrack is no longer
continued it has been discontinued and
Kali Linux has taken the place of
backtrack within which are all the tools
that you see on your screen Metasploit
is one of the most favorite penetration
testing tools of hackers and ethical
hackers there are a lot of inbuilt
exploits over there and we'll be doing a
demo at the end of the session on this
nmap is the information gathering tool
which will scan for live devices scan
for open ports protocols and services
beef would be an application testing
tool that would help us find exploits
within applications nessus vulnerability
scanner is a network and host based
scanner that would help you identify
vulnerabilities within such hosts
Wireshark is a Network's refer which
allows you to capture Network packets
and and analyze them to see if there are
there is any information worth capturing
within those packets SQL map is a
automated tool used for SQL injection
attacks so you don't even have to craft
your queries for SQL injection it will
be done by the SQL map tool you just
need to identify whatever is possible
through the queries that this SQL is
going to create and then based on the
activity that you've identified you just
need to redefine your search parameters
to get access to the database we will be
doing a demo on SQL map or SQL map as
well and then there is John the Ripper
John the Ripper is a tool that is used
for password cracking so dictionary
attacks Brute Force attacks are done
using John the Ripper what is a
dictionary attack a dictionary attack is
an attack where we create list of all
probable passwords stored them in a txt
file and run that list against the
password tool to see if any of those
passwords are going to match a Brute
Force attack is trying the same attack
but with every permutation and
combination of the alphabet that we have
and we are going to try to figure out if
we are able to crack the password at all
so these are just some of the tools for
every tool there are another supporting
100 tools or more than that like for an
SS vulnerability scanner you'll have
college vulnerability scanner you have
GFI Lan card and there are other lots of
other softwares out there but these are
some of the most commonly utilized tools
let's look at the Metasploit attack
Metasploit is a framework of penetration
testing that makes hacking very simple
you just need to know how to utilize the
tool you need to identify the volume D
associated with a particular exploit and
then run the exploit on Metasploit we'll
be demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits in active exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit please exploits wait for
incoming requests and exploit them as
soon as they connect they can also be
used in conjunction with emails and web
browsers so in passive exploits we
create a preload we like a reverse
connection payload we send it to the
victim once a victim installs that
software the machine will then initiate
a connection to us our machine will be
in a lesson mode and then we will once
the software is executed at the end we
would then try to connect and exploit
that particular vulnerability this is
the Practical that we'll be doing on
Metasploit so let's move on with the
demos and then we'll see what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look at some of the demos that we
had talked about in the ethical hacking
and penetration testing module we are
going to look at three different demos
the first one is going to be a SQL
injection attack that we are going to
perform on this tool that we have the
second one is a password tracking attack
on Windows 7 and a third one is a meter
reader based or a Metasploit based shell
shock attack on a Linux based web server
so let's get cracking I've powered on
this virtual machine which is the ovas
broken web application it is a tool that
is provided for people who want to
enhance their skills and they can
practice how to do these attacks in a
legal manner so we are going to go to
this site I'm just going to open up my
browser the IP address is 71.132 and
that's the ovas broken web application
that we want to utilize we are going to
head off to mutility2 and we are going
to look at a SQL injection attack where
we want to bypass authentication now
this takes us to the login screen so we
can just try our luck here and see that
the authentication mechanism works the
account does not exist so the username
and pass food that you have supplied is
not the correct one so we want to ensure
that there's a SQL database and we can
try to attack it and see if we can
bypass the authentication now what we
want to do is we want to create a SQL
based malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's an error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried
earlier when we used a proper text-based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
gave us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what this queries are
all about how the syntax works here
we're just going to see if we can create
a malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is
create the query over here I'm going to
give it a comparison so we're going to
give it R 1 equals one space hyphenation
space and if you now click login you
should be able to bypass authentication
and you can see user has been
authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercises in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database an Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
at a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query work wonders where it allowed
us to bypass authentication so it also
depends on what kind of a page I am and
what query would be accepted at this
point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we are
calling upon when we are connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user or password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or in
give it a condition single code or one
equals one space hyphenation space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a term of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the userlookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the SQL
injection attack that we wanted to look
at let's move on to password cracking
now this is a Windows 7 machine that we
have I'm just going to do a very basic
password tracking example we're just
going to log in now here the assumption
is that we are able to log in we have
access to a computer and we want to
check out other users who are using this
computer and see if we can find out
their passwords so that we can log in as
a different user steal data if required
and we wouldn't be to blame if there are
any logs that are created so here we've
got a tool called Kane enable that is
installed right here now I'm already an
administrator on this machine I'm
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password I can crack and thus I would be
able to get access through their account
and then do any malicious activity right
so this allows me to go into a cracker
tool and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the users and
passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so I'm just
going to click on the plus sign and I'm
going to import hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does Windows store its passwords
and what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as a
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click so
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users or hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
the user called virus as well and you
can see that this is the hash value of
the password that is being utilized now
there's a particular format for a hash
value for Windows and how it stores but
once we have these hash values let's say
if I want to crack this password there
are various attacks that we can do for
example a dictionary based attack or a
Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so we
are going to try to create an ntlm hash
attack and here we are going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and lowercase A through Z uppercase A
through Z numeric zero through nine and
all the special characters let's say the
password is between 7 and 16 characters
and this is the character set that you
want to try the Brute Force attack on
what is a group Force attack it is an
attack where the computer is going to
try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100 successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can do which can easily identify this
data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how we can get access
to users and passwords there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
Linux web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a
Kali Linux machine to hack that device
and I'm going to just power off my
Windows 7 machine give it a minute till
it boots up now this is also a demo
machine that we have which has its own
pre-configured vulnerabilities so here
we've got something from the pen testers
lab and has a shell shock vulnerability
implemented inside shell shock
vulnerability affects Linux Mac and Unix
based operating systems for a particular
version of The Bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we are trying to do here
is we are going to use the Kali Linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use Metasploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the IP
address we have no idea what the IP
address is we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we are able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my appears is this
with a subnet mask of
255255255.0 so I want to see if there
are any other machines that are live in
the same subnet and we are doing a ping
switch over here to identify which
machines are live in a minute we'll get
all the IP addresses 71.1 to 133 254 and
128 we know that VR 128 at this point in
time uh 254 is the DHCP server so we're
assuming that 133 is the machine that we
want to look at and let's then try to
see if we can scan that machine 133 and
we're going to do an intense scan to
find out which ports are open what
services are running over there and if
it is whether the pin test machine that
we were looking for you can see of the
start Port 22 and Port 80 and somewhere
here it's going to give us the ports
that are open and the details about
those ports and somewhere here it will
tell us that this is the pen tester lab
machine that we wanted which is correct
so now we want to do a vulnerability
analysis on this what we're going to do
is I'm going to use another GUI based
tool called Sparta which I can just find
out from here Sparta uses two tools in
the background nmap tool and a tool
called Necto so we're just going to
start scanning 192 168
71.133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information there we are that's the
nikto tool coming in scanning on Port 80
which is uh which means that it's a web
server using HTTP it tells us it's an
Apache HD httpd 2.2.21 and gives us the
22 port number as well if we head over
to the tab of nickto or let's look at
the screenshot first this is what the
website will would be looking like and
Necto gives us the options over here it
tells us that there is a vulnerability
over here for shell shock and this is
the path where the vulnerability is
going to exist so what we are going to
do we go back to the command line sorry
you open up a new one minimize all these
other windows and you're going to open
up Metasploit Metasploit is a
penetration testing tool that is used by
most hackers and ethical hackers to test
applications and test existing exploits
and vulnerabilities so just give it a
minute till it starts you can see there
are already around 1700 exploits right
here we're going to see all those
exploits with these commands there we
are sorry for the typo and it will just
give us a list of all the exploits that
are stored in Metasploit in this version
so all of these are windows based if we
scroll up we will be looking at other
vulnerabilities as well or exploits the
unique space exploits line Max OS X
multi-exploits and we're looking for a
exploit for a multi-based Apache or HTTP
let's go up let's look at so this is the
one that you're looking for Apache mod
CGI bash environmental executable so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to copy it go back to the bottom
say use exploit and paste the one that
we wanted press enter say show options
so it will ask us to configure this I'm
just going to configure it based on the
knowledge that we have set our host
which is the remote host the victims
machine so we put in the IP address it
asks us for the Target URI so that's the
path that we saw set Target URI to CGI
hyphen bin slash status enter now with
exploit we need to find a payload that
is going to give us the output that we
want so we say show payloads and it will
give us a list of all the compatible
payloads with this exploit and we want
to create a reverse TCP connection which
is this so we know it's a Linux
operating system we want this payload to
be set so set payload press enter that's
the payload coming in show options now
that you have set the payload this is
the options for the exploit and now we
want to set our options for the payloads
as well so we are creating a reverse TCP
connection which means we are remotely
executing code at the victim side and
making the victim connect back to our
machine which means we need to set up a
listener so I need to put my IP address
over here set localhost or lhost
192.168
71.128 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack you can see that
it has created a meter Builder session
at the victim side and it has opened up
a session so if I do a PWD now PWD is a
Linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connect it to where www CGI hyphen win
do an LS it will list all the files
that's the status file file over there
do a CD backslash it will take us to the
root of this machine if you are someone
who is interested in building a cutter
in cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply lens
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered in a world
where digital Footprints are traced
censorship looms and cyber threats lurk
in the shadows the need for a shielded
connection has never been more crucial
that's where VPN swoop in like digital
superheroes whisking your way into a
realm of secure browsing Anonymous
identities and unrestricted access to
the vast vendors of the web welcome back
tech Enthusiast and curious minds today
we are diving into the mysterious realm
of vpns but how exactly does this
technological Marvel operate how does it
cloak your online activities and your
true location feeling curious well today
we will demystify the inner workings of
vpns and help you with the knowledge
picture this you are shipping your
favorite beverage at a local cafe
enjoying the convenience of public Wi-Fi
little do you know lurking nearby could
be cyber criminals itching to snatch
your sensitive information but fret note
with a VPN by your side your connection
transforms into a impregnable Fortress
encrypting your data and shielding it
from prying eyes so grab your
metaphorical passports faster your
virtual seat belts and join me on this
captivating Expedition through the inner
workings of VPN technology without
further Ado let the quest to unveil the
wonders of vpns begin before we begin if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered if these are the types of videos
you would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press the Bell
icon to never miss on further content
now let's get started here we'll start
with what is a VPN then we'll see how
does a VPN work and then we will see the
types of vpns and then see the
advantages of VPN and then explore the
disadvantages of VPN so starting with
what is a VPN VPN stands for virtual
private Network it's a service that
helps you stay private and secure while
browsing the internet a VPN creates a
secure encrypted connection between your
device and the internet making it
impossible for anyone to intercept your
data and now we'll see how does a VPN
works so to understand how our VPN Works
let's imagine and let's imagine a tunnel
that connects your device to the
internet and all your data passes
through this tunnel ensuring privacy and
security when you you use a VPN it
encrypts all your data on your device
before sending it through the tunnel to
the internet this encryption ensures
that even if someone intercepts your
data they won't be able to decipher it
your data is encrypted and your IP
address is hidden making it difficult
for any to trace your online activities
the encryption tunnel created by a VPN
protects your data from hackers cyber
criminals and even your internet service
provider it works by scrambling your
data into an unreadable code that can
only be decrypted by your device and the
VPN server when you connect to a website
through a VPN server your connection
appears to come from the server rather
than your device this helps protect your
privacy and prevents websites from
tracking your real location so this is
how a VPN works now Moving on but before
moving on you could just see this
diagram and you would be very clear how
does this VPN works so so here is the
VPN tunnel through which the encrypted
data flows so when the encrypted data
flows from the VPN tunnel even the
internet service provider can't detect
your IP address and this IP address or
this encrypted data that would be
converted into some codes and that would
be detected by the VPN server and that
increases the privacy and then you would
access the internet or the website you
want to access so we are done with how
VPN works now we'll see some types of
VPN so there are two main types of VPN
the first one is Remote Access VPN and
the second is side to side VPN so remote
access vpns allow individuals to
securely connect to a private Network
while side to side vpns they are used by
businesses to connect multiple locations
and vpns use different encryption
protocols to ensure the security of your
connection and here we have openvpn that
is an example and is an open source
protocol known for its strong security
features it's important to choose a VPN
provider that uses reliable encryption
protocols to safeguard your data now
we'll see why we use VPN or why you need
a VPN now that we have understood how
our VPN Works let's talk about why we
need one so first and foremost a VPN
offers privacy by encrypting your data
and routing it through secure servers a
VPN Shields or online activities from
your internet service provider that is
ISP government agencies or hackers it
keeps your personal information such as
browsing history passwords and credit
card details away from prying eyes and
the next feature is anonymity it's an
another significant advantage of using a
VPN when you connect to the internet
through a VPN it masks your original IP
address and assign your different one
this makes it difficult for anyone to
track your online activities back to
your real location or identity the next
feature we have is security
it's a top priority when using a VPN by
encrypting your data a VPN ensures that
it remains confidential and secure
during transmission this is particularly
crucial when using public Wi-Fi networks
which are often vulnerable to cyber
attacks a VPN adds an extra layer of
protection safeguarding your sensitive
information from potential hackers
lurking on the same network now move
into another feature that is bypass
filters and unlock websites so this is
one of the key features of a VPN and its
ability to pass that is bypass filters
and analog websites in certain scenarios
websites may be restricted or blocked by
organizations schools or governments
with a VPN you can bypass these
restrictions and gain access to the
content you desire whether it's social
networking sites streaming platforms or
any other blogged content a VPN allows
you to enjoy internet Freedom the next
we have is seasonal restrictions so
Regional restrictions can also be
overcome with a VPN
some online services and websites are
available only to specific regions or
countries by connecting to a VPN server
in the desired location you can change
your IP address and appear as if you are
accessing the internet from that region
this enables you to access jio blocked
content and take advantage of exclusive
offers or services and now the next
feature is changing your IP address so
using a VPN also allows you to change
your IP address which enhances your
online privacy and security your ISP can
track your online activities and collect
data on your browsing habits however
when you use a VPN your real IP address
is hidden making it difficult for anyone
including your internet service provider
to monitor your internet usage online
anonymity is a valuable benefit of using
a VPN by masking your IP address and
encrypting your data a VPN helps protect
your identity online websites and online
services won't be able to track your
activities or collect personal
information about you without your
consent while vpns offer numerous
advantages it's important to be aware of
some potential disadvantages so vpns
slow down your internet connection and
it could be sometimes that they slow
down new internet connections that is
due to the encryption and three routing
of data the distance between your device
and the VPN server as well as the
server's capacity can impact your
connection speed another consideration
is that vpns may keep logs of your
activities despite claims of a no logs
policy some VPN providers May store
certain data it's essential to research
and choose a reputable VPN service that
prioritizes user privacy and has
transparent policies regarding data
retention next block VPN users that is
limitation on data usage or speed lastly
while there are free VPN services
available they often have limitations on
data usage or speed for regular and
reliable VPN usage opting for a paid
subscription is required mandate premium
VPN Services typically offer better
speeds more server locations and
stronger security features in conclusion
a VPN is a valuable tool for protecting
your online security privacy and
anonymity it encrypts your data mask
your IP address and allows you to bypass
restrictions and access bloat content
while there are a few drawbacks to
consider the advantages of using a VPN
far outweigh the potential downsides so
whether you are browsing the internet
using public Wi-Fi or accessing jio blog
content a VPN is an effective solution
to safeguard your online identity and
keep your data secure with that we have
reached the end of this tutorial let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers with the next generation
of Internet exchanges focused on maximum
privacy and security a variety of ways
have been enforced to maintain them as
such censorship has been shifted from
the streets to the digital domain it
forces the standard citizen to
alternative ways to maintain anonymity
major weapon in this battle for privacy
and security is the top browser an
independent browser meant to browse the
internet file reeling information
through the Tor Network it serves as a
meaningful alternative to the standard
internet browsing habits to better
understand the purpose of this browser
and such we must learn about the work of
the Tor Network featuring its own
routing protocol the top browser is an
easy way to maintain anonymity while
browsing without emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start at the explanation of what is
the Tor Network and its significance in
the working of the top browser
we take a look at the onion routing
protocol and how it transmits the data
from the client devices to the tort
directories in order to circumvent
government censorship
moving on we learn a few features of the
Tor Browser and the distinct advantages
the Tor Network provides next we learn
the difference between using a VPN and a
Tor to anonymize internet usage and
finally we have a live demonstration of
the Tor Browser anonymization features
in action
let's move on to learning about the Tor
Network
Tor short for the onion router it's an
open source privacy Network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
Tor was initially developed and solely
used by the US Navy to protect sensitive
government Communications before the
network was made publicly available
the digital era has disrupted the
traditional way of doing things in every
sector of the economy the rapid rise in
development and innovation of digital
products has given way to frequent data
breaches and cyber thefts in response
consumers are increasingly opting for
products that offer data privacy and
cyber security
Tor is one such underground Network that
was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the Tor
Network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security concerns
the Tor Network intercepts the traffic
from your browser and bounces a user's
request of a random number of other user
IP addresses
then the data is passed to the user
requester Final Destination
these random users are volunteer devices
which are called as nodes or relays the
Tor Network disguises your identity by
encrypting the traffic and moving it
across different Tower relays within the
network
the torn Network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router
to operate within the torn Network a
user has to install the Tor Browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the
Tor Network it has its own feature set
which we will be covering over later in
this video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the Tor Network must follow a
unique protocol known as The Onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique characteristics
in our normal Network usage the data is
transmitted directly
the sender has data packets to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable moreover it becomes very easy
to trace the origin of such requests on
many occasions websites with
questionable and controversial content
are blocked from the ISP this is
possible since the ISP is able to detect
and spy on user information passing
through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's IP address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address
this is the last address which is also
known as the exit node this last node
decrypts the encrypted data and finally
relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user
the Tor Network obfuscates user IP
addresses from unwanted surveillance by
keeping the user's request untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way Tor works
let us learn more about the Tor Browser
the top browser was developed by a
non-profit organization as a part of the
Tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced
the Tor Browser is a browser forked from
the popular Firefox that anonymizes
their web traffic using the torn Network
if you are investigating a competitor
researching and opposing litigant in a
legal dispute or just think it's creepy
for your ISP or the government to know
what websites you visit the top browser
might be the right solution
before the top browser were developed
using that Network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the top browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers intor and
guarantee the privacy of the data
Exchange
a major feature of the Tor Browser is
the ability to delete all browser
history cookies and tracking data the
moment it is closed every new launch of
the browser opens an empty slate having
a usage habits from being tracked and
singled out
a major feature that is the highlight of
the Tor Network is the availability of
onion links
only a small portion of the World Wide
Web is available to the general public
we have the Deep Web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
Tor Browser gives you access to these
dot onion websites which are only
available within the Tor Network
onion is a special use top level domain
which designates an anonymous onion
service which is also known as a hidden
service similar to The Links of the Deep
Web these onion links provide services
like online shopping cryptocurrency and
many other products not available in the
consumer Internet space
often being considered as a Haven for
illegal activities and sales on your
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by authorities
browsing the web over tour is slower
than the clear net due to the multiple
layers of encryption
some web services also blocked our users
Tor Browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving towards
anonymity properties
let us take a look at some of the
advantages of using the Tor Browser of a
standard web browsers
the highlight of using the Tor Browser
is to maintain anonymity over the
Internet the cause for such requests can
differ from person to person but all of
these concerns are answered by the torn
Network
routing the information via multiple
nodes and relay servers make it entirely
difficult for the ISP to keep a track of
usage data
the entire top project is designed to be
completely free and open source allowing
the code for the browser to be inspected
and audited by Third parties helps in
the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile devices
a number of websites are blocked by
governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via Tor usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the Tor Browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive circumstances
many people believe that a VPN offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between them
coming to the first point of difference
Tor is completely free and open source
all of the code for the browser and the
network can be audited and has been
cleared for security concerns when it
comes to VPN there are many different
brands which have open source clients
but the same cannot be said for their
counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stolen further
moving on Tor has multiple relay points
in his data transfer protocol between
the server and the receiver there are
three different IP nodes that number can
increase but it will always be more than
two
once the data is passed from the
cylinder it goes through all of those
Julia points while in the case of a VPN
the connection is made from the client
device to the VPN server and then to the
requested destination there is no other
IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a
one-to-one between the client and a VPN
as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
Tor is consistent if you use Tor Browser
every single request passes through the
same layer of encryption and follows the
same routing protocol in the case of a
VPN different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multi-hop
some prefer a single one-to-one
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the Tor Network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward for instance in the case
of vpns many such vpns are hosted by
adware companies or are being monitored
by Central governments to note the usage
information
now that we have a better understanding
of the Tor Browser and its routing let
us take a look at how the Tor Browser
can anonymize and protect our internet
usage
on opening up the Tor Browser for the
first time this is the page that you are
going to be welcomed with you have the
option of connecting to the Tor Network
before we start our browsing
so let's press connect
and we can see that it is connected
coming to the anonymization let's check
my current location on Google Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra
if we check this same link on the Tor
Browser we should get a different
address
now every link that we open in the Tor
Browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can see
it's showing a German IP and the state
of Bavaria
this is how the anonymization works
there is no VPN configured there is no
proxy attached it's straight up this out
of the box settings that come inbuilt
with the Tor Browser
similarly we have an option of cleaning
up the data let's say if you want to
refresh your location and you want to
use a different ID for the next browsing
session if we just restart it once
and you can have to check it again
we should be seeing a different country
this time
as you can see we have Netherlands right
now so this is how we can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that it
cannot be tracked when it browsing the
internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the Tor
Network
as you can see these kind of links do
not open in the Google Chrome browser
but once we copy these over to the Tor
Browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the Tor
Network
this is kind of an alternative Wikipedia
website where we can find articles to
read and more information to learn
similarly we have another onion link
over here
which is once again available only for
the tall browser hmm
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire
similarly we have found a hidden wallet
which is a cryptocurrency wallet which
is specifically for dark web members
this operates over the Tor Network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing money
all of the transactions that occur over
the Tor Network are almost impossible to
track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available in this video we will cover
topics like what is ransomware attack
how does a ransomware attack work types
of ransomware attacks effects of
ransomware on the business how to
prevent from the ransomware attack and
the last one is popular ransomware
attacks and let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are attacking on a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
as we know the demand for cyber security
person is skyrocketing so if you want to
master the field of cyber security then
simply runs postgraduate program in
cyber security in collaboration with MIT
is clearly the right choice for you so
this postgraduate program in cyber
security is designed to equip you the
skills required to become an expert in
the rapidly growing field of the cyber
security this cyber security program
aims to help you to stay ahead of all
the latest cyber security Trends so key
features of this program is simply on
postgraduate program certificate master
class is from MIT faculty featuring
modules from MIT SSC and EC Council
access to ceh Kit 25 plus Hands-On
project and many more this cyber
security certification program began
with introductory level skills and then
progress to the advanced cyber security
technique these programs cover all the
essential skills you will need to become
an expert in the field of cyber security
cyber security is one of the top concern
of the business today in an industry
from securing data to anticipating cyber
attacks and placing Enterprise wide
safeguards to prevent them employers
worldwide are increasingly looking for
qualified cyber security Professor to
join that so what are you waiting for
find the course link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll today
so let's get started in 2015 the Tesla
crypto ransomware rapidly spread causing
significant disruption to numerous
Gamers following extending gaming
session Gamers were alarmed to find an
unfamiliar tax while label Ransom note
on their desktop the content of this
text file is informed that the hacking
group had taken control of their game
files and private document encrypting
them in an unreadable format to regain
access to their valuable data each gamer
was required to pay a ransom of 500
worth of bitcoin to a specific Bitcoin
address upon payment they would receive
the master key necessary to decrypt
their files this was the Tesla Crypt
ransomware move on to their
understanding what exactly are answerver
attacks is all about so what is a
ransomware attack a ransomware attack
refers to a type of malware designed to
encrypt personal information and
document prompting the victim to pay
attention in order to decrypt them this
payment is typically made using
cryptocurrency to maintain anonymity
although other payment methods may also
be utilized even after the money has
been sent there is no guarantee that the
hacker will send the decryption key or
unlock the files but in certain
sensitive situation victim makes the
payment hoping for the best so the
attackers bringing out the attacks
mainly the targeted renowned names of
any organization which leads to a lot of
damage and theft to a valuable
information so now let's understand how
such an attacks works so how does our
ransomware attacks work the first one is
the spread of ransomware only start with
phishing attacks a ransomware attack
gains access to a victim device through
infected emails messages and malicious
sites and encrypt the data in that
device the ransomware uses simple
asymmetric encryption algorithms blocks
a user's files and make them difficult
to decrypt without knowing the key and
the third one is it also Maps the
location for targeted file type that
include file stored locally and mapped
in and mapped network accessible devices
and the fourth one is it can also spread
wire malware transmitted via untrusted
application installation or even a
compromised wireless network and the
fifth one is rent server adds
instruction files describing the pay for
decryption process then use is those
files to present a ransom node to the
user now let's understand types of
friend server attacks so there are
numerous types of ransomware available
but they mainly fall into three
categories the first one is Locker
ransomware it is a type of malware that
blocks standard computer functions from
being accessed until the payment to the
hacker is not complete it shows a lock
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for primary purposes
and the second one is crypto ransomware
this sensorwear encrypts the local files
and documents to computers once the file
are encrypted finding the decryption key
is impossible unless a ransomware
version is ruled and the keys are
already available online and the third
one is scareware it is a fake software
that claims to have detected a virus or
other issue on your computer and direct
you to pay to resolve the problem some
scalware locks the computer while other
flood the screen with pop-up alerts
without damaging the files so after
seeing types of ransomware let's move
forward and see some effects of
ransomware on the businesses so the
impact on the answerver attacks on a
business can severally destructive as
per the report ransomware has inflicted
staggering cost of over 8 billion on
business in the past year so let's see
what are the reasons first one is data
loss businesses may suffer significant
data losses resulting in critical
information being inaccessible or
permanently destroyed the second one is
downtime and infrastructure compromise
ransomware compromise the business
infrastructure leading to disruptive
downtime periods and the third one is
costly recovery efforts the recovery
process after a ransomware attack can be
expensive the expensive might surpass
the actual Ransom amount and the fourth
one is customer loss The Fallout from a
con ransomware attack may lead to losing
customers who may seek Services
elsewhere so these effects highlight the
severity of ransomware attacks and
underscore the importance of robust
cyber security measure to safeguard
businesses against such so now let's
move forward word and see how to prevent
the ransomware attacks so how can one
prevent ransomware attacks Security
Experts recommend the following measures
to protect against ransomware threats so
the first one is regularly backup on
Computing devices to ensure data can be
restored in case of any attack and the
second one is conduct an inventory like
of all assets to have a comprehensive
understanding of the organization
digital lens and the third one is keep
software including antivirus programs up
to date address known vulnerabilities
and the fourth one is educate educate
end users to avoid clicking on links in
emails or opening emails attachment from
unknown sources so by implementing these
messages individuals and organization
can enhance their defense against
ransomware and mitigate potential risk
effectively so now let's move forward
and see some popular ransomware attacks
in history
so here are five most popular ransomware
attacks that occurred in recent years
and grabbed the entire world's attention
the first one is Wanna Cry
in 2017 and infected thousands of
computer in over 150 countries the
second one is Patia Patel and somewhere
is an encrypting malware that first
surfaced in 2016 it encrypts critical
files and hold them hostile unless you
pay and the third one is server server
appeared in 2016 that spread through
phishing emails and encrypted users
files and data with Advanced encryption
methods and the fourth one is bad rapid
bad rapid ransomware is reported to be
an improved variant of the patial
enzymeware it locks up the victims
computer servers and the other files
preventing them from regarding access
until are Ransom in the form of Bitcoin
is paid and the last one is locking
released in 2016 log is a file type of
ransomware sent using emails demanding
payment through an invoice in the form
of tinted Microsoft Word document
containing infectious macro if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a profile
man who at least sits to switch careers
with cyber security by learning from the
experts then try giving a short to
Simply lens postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices
many malicious programs like Trojan
viruses worms and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive data
let's take a look at the introduction
for two different types of malware virus
androgen
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus program
a computer virus is a type of malicious
program that on execution replicates
itself they get attached to different
files and programs which are termed as
host programs by inserting their code if
the attachment succeeds the targeted
program is termed as infected with a
computer virus now let's take a look at
the trojanos
Trojan Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create bad doors into a
system to allow the Cyber criminal to
steal our information
let's take a look how they function
after getting installed into a system
firstly we have virus programs the
computer virus must contain two parts to
infect the system
first is a search routine which locates
new files and data that is to be
infected by the virus program
and the second part is known as the copy
routine which is necessary for the
program to copy itself into the targeted
file which is located by the search
routine now let's take a look at the
Trojan Horse functioning
for Trojan horses entryway into a system
is through emails that may look
legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the closure
program gets installed and infects the
system
they also infect the system on the
execution of infected application or the
executable file and attacks a system
now that we understand what virus and
Provisions are let's understand
different types of virus androgens
let's take a look at different types of
viruses
the first one is known as the boot
sector virus this type of virus damages
the booting section of the system by
infecting the masterbot record which is
also known as MBI this damages the boot
sector section by targeting the hard
disk of the system
then we have the macro virus microvirus
is a type of virus that gets embedded
into the document related data and is
executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale
and lastly we have the direct action
virus
this type of virus gets attached to
executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system
once the infection of the file is
completed they exit the system which is
also the reason it is known as a
non-resident virus
let's take a look at different types of
Trojans
the first type of Trojan is the back
door
they are designed to create a backdoor
in the system on execution of an
infected program
they provide remote access of a system
to the hacker this way the Cyber
criminal can steal our system data and
may use it for illegal activities next
we have
Crick Source Trojan
they enter the system by clicking the
random pop-ups which we come across on
the internet
they tell the user to give their
personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the Cyber Criminal
and the last Trojan type is Ransom
Trojan this type of Trojan program after
entering the system blocks the user from
accessing its own system and also
affects the system function
the Cyber criminal Demands a ransom from
the targeted user for the removal of the
Trojan program from the device now that
we understand some details regarding
viruses and Trojan let's solve a
question
the question is J equals the knights
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in a
system
now
the actual question is what could be the
reason behind a systems problem option a
macro virus option b Ransom Trojan
option C Bank load version
give your answers in the comment section
now let's understand how to detect the
activity of viruses and Trojan in our
system
to detect virus or Trojan activity in a
system we can refer to the following
points for viruses we have slowing down
of the system and frequent application
freeze shows that the infection of the
virus is present in the system
then we have the viruses can also steal
sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected logout from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system
for Trojan we have frequent system
crashes and system also faces slow
reaction time
then we have there are more random
pop-ups from the system which may
indicate Trojan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the desktop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a Trojan program
next let's take a look at a famous Cyber
attack for virus and a trojanos
for virus we have the mydum virus which
was identified in the ER 2004 which
affected over 50 million systems by
creating a network of sending spam
emails
which was to gain backdoor access into
our systems
next for the Trojan Horse we have the
emote at Trojan program
which is specifically designed for
financial theft and for stealing Bank
related information
next we have few points for how to
prevent virus entry or Trojan attack for
a system
the most basic way of virus protection
is to using antivirus and do regular
viruses can this will prevent virus
entry in the system and also having more
than one antivirus provides much better
protection
then avoid visiting uncertified websites
can also prevent virus entry into a
system
then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry
for erosion we have using certified
softwares from legal sites to prevent
any Trojan activity in a system
and also avoid clicking random pop-ups
that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against Trojan horses is
a good habit
now that we have reached the end of the
video Let's Take a look what we learned
for the first part we saw the main
objective of the virus is to harm the
data and information in a system whereas
for the Trojan we have stealing of the
data files and information
effect of viruses is more drastic in
comparison to the Trojan horses
then we have viruses which are
non-remote programs whereas Trojan
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
Trojan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection
as the name suggests SQL injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject Mauritius input into a SQL
statement so SQL stands for structured
query language which is a language used
by an application to interact with the
database now normally this attack is
targeted towards a database to extract
the data that is stored within however
the vulnerability does not line the
database itself the vulnerability will
always lie in the application
it is the developer's prerogative of how
to develop the application how to
configure it to prevent SQL injection
queries from happening a database is
created to answer questions and if a
question is asked it is supposed to
answer it database needs to be
configured for some amount of security
but the vulnerability the flaw here for
SQL injection will always lie in the
application itself it does how the
application interacts with the database
that needs to be modified that needs to
be maintained by the developer rather
than just configuring the database
itself so the attacker at this point in
time when they send a query to the
application will form a malformed query
by injecting a particular command or an
operator that is recognized by the SQL
language and if that operator is passed
through the application to the database
then the database basically gets cracked
or does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called ovasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this on
till this power is on I'm going to show
you where we can download this utility
from so you can just
look for ovasp broken web application
project download you'll find it on
sourcefold.net click on the link
you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9 GB download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or every
Oracle virtual box
now this is an application that has been
developed by ovasp which stands for open
web application security project which
is a not-for-profit organization and
periodically releases the most top 10
risks that an application uh will face
for that particular year
so they have given a web application
with inbuilt vulnerabilities for
professionals like us to practice upon
to developables our skills upon because
doing this in the real world is illegal
I cannot go onto a website to
demonstrate how a SQL injection attack
works uh neither should you try your
hands on it till you become very well
rehearsed with it so till to upgrade
your skills to upskill yourself please
download this machine host it in a
VMware Workstation or a Oracle virtual
box and you can uh then try your skills
on it right so just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 71.132
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 192 168 71.132
and you'll see the OS Brooklyn web
application project and there are a lot
of training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutility over here
uh this gives you the uh OS top 10 risks
for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest one so
far uh but the difference between 2013
and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection
attacks blind SQL injection and then
there is a tool called SQL map which is
available freely on on your Linux
machines Kali Linux or parrot Linux
whichever you want to use uh for your
practice targets and so on so forth so
if I just take you here for bypass
Authentication
and this is a regular login page that an
application may have right you look at a
username you look at password you type
that in and you log in so let's say I
don't know a password here I'm just
going to type in the username test
password as
psswrd I'll try to log in and it shows
me that the account does not exist so
the authentication mechanism does work I
did try type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single quote
or one equals one space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it gives me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and we're going to look at the
basics of SQL injection so looking at
that small demo looking now let's look
at what types of secret injections are
available so the first is inbound SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within in band error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a time-based attack and the
third one is out of bound SQL injection
attack now what is n-band SQL injection
attack in bandage where we are either
attempting the error base or the union
base what is error based uh we send a
query to the database we craft a query
to the database and it generates an
error message and it dumps the error
message right in front of us on the
screen that makes us realize that there
is a flaw and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft I will further queries as we go
ahead
whereas Union based is it is where we
combine multiple statements at the same
time so if you look at the URL earlier
in the URL you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would a error based uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember the username we gave it a
single code or one equals one space
hyphen hyphen space we gave it the
condition right so basically what it did
was the single quote is an operator that
goes to the database selects the default
uh table in the user tables in this
database column and then Compares it to
the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was is 1 equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default user table that
was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the account doesn't exist comes
back again because the condition was
false and instead of comparing the user
account to the password it basically
compared the user account to the
condition so if I give it a single quote
or 1 equals one hyphen iPhone space
and login you can see that this is a
correct condition and thus we are able
to log in now before we even go to that
extent if I just forget the condition
over here and just give it a single
quote the operator and I send this
operator to the database and I click on
login you will see that it generates an
error which is right on top and it tells
us the line the file where the error
happened and you can see it happened in
the MySQL handler.php file right and
then it gives us the message you have an
error in your SQL syntax check the
manual that corresponds to your MySQL
server version for the right syntax to
use now why would a hacker want to do
this in the first place because there
are different types of databases so
there is a MySQL Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL
Oracle SQL IBM db2 all of these are
variations of the SQL database uh they
use the SQL language however every
database has its own Command right there
they have their own syntax they have
their own specific commands that are
utilized for the database so in this
scenario the hacker wants to identify
what database is being currently
utilized so they can craft those
particular queries so now with this
injection with just me sending the quote
and the error getting generated I now
come to know that we are using a MySQL
server and the version of that server is
5.1.73 and the rest of the information
about uh where the handlers are located
and so on so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so error base attack is where you
generate these kind of Errors uh and you
get this information the union base is
where you craft your queries within the
URL or you can try to combine multiple
statements within the input fields and
try to generate a response from that
when we come to Boolean based SQL
injection uh sends a SQL query to the
database which forces the application to
return a different wizard depending on
whether the query turns it through Auto
false result so basically if the input
is false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false there's
one input that is false the other input
that is true input B the output would be
true and so on so forth right so
depending on the result from the inputs
the attacker will come to know which
input is true with this you can then
access the database of the website so
you're trying to figure out by sending
out multiple inputs and then analyzing
the output to see what exactly which
command exactly worked what was the
resultant output of that command thus
from this kind of an information the
hacker can infer their next step forward
then you have time based SQL injections
uh now there are times when a database
administered or an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and thus have disabled
verbose error messages now what is a
verbose error message the error message
that we saw right here
is a verbose error message that means
that the message gives out details the
message gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if
they have sanitized these errors
and you no longer can generate these
errors and thus you cannot figure out
what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply learn
okay
foreign
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbal error that we saw here
so this gives us a detail error of what
went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
where the query went wrong and etc etc
etc whereas on this side where there's
some there's a lot of security that goes
in here so you can see that it doesn't
generate a error it does get a generic
page in front of you so in that case
what does a hacker do so the hacker then
injects a time-based uh query in the URL
which allows us to verify whether the
command is being executed or not so we
put in a Time weight
let's say 10 seconds of time wait so if
we the moment we inject the query if the
query times for 10 seconds and then gets
executed that means that the SQL
injection is possible however
if we inject the query and it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
there enabled in the database management
system that has been used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error by the database
administrator where you have enabled
functions and not sanitize them so you
have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be executed a user level
with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions
to be to be enabled at the dbms and
there is an administrative account that
can have access to them at that point in
time and out of bound injection attack
is possible so let's look at how our
website works right uh how SQL works on
a website now the website is constructed
of HTML hypertext markup language which
would include JavaScript for
functionality cascading style sheets for
the mapping of the website right and
then the react.js and whatnot uh for for
the functionality now when we send a
query to the website it is normally
using the HTTP protocol or https
protocol when the query reaches the
application the application would then
go ahead and generate the SQL query uh
at the client side you'll have all these
scripting languages coming in on the
front end that we can utilize to craft
queries and then send them across at the
server side you will have uh databases
like Oracle MySQL MSC well and so on so
forth that will then execute those
queries right so just to give you an
example if I use a tool called Postman
what we generally do when we craft a
query is we send out a get request
to the website and then we'll see the
response from the site with the HTML
code and everything so this is a tool
that is utilized by software testers to
test the responses that you're going to
get from various websites so on the left
hand side you can see I've used it on
quite a bit uh here we have an example
for gmail.com so let's continue with
that so this is a get request being sent
to Gmail the moment I sent it is going
to create an HTTP request and send it
across the response that I get is this
this is the HTML code for gmail.com
right these are the cookies these are
the headers that include information so
you can see this is a text HTML
character set utilized is utf-8 and the
configuration that has been done with
the application right so this is where
uh everything comes in this is the
cookie that has been sent with that
particular request that I had sent out
now if you Analyze This query right so
when we went on to this application and
I typed in that single quote and we
generated this error right uh you can
see that the application converted this
into a SQL query so the query was select
username from accounts where the
username in quote single quotes and we
use this support right the single quote
right there so uh that's where we use
that operator and that's where the
exception error occurred so these are
the kind of queries that are structured
by the application and then taken on to
the database for execution when we type
in uh it is a HTTP get request with the
username and password within that query
that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a SQL query
sends it to the database and the
database responds with the appropriate
response so how do we prevent SQL
injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterized
queries these statements make sure that
the parameters pass into SQL statements
are treated in a safe manner so for
example we saw that the single code was
an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place right so here what we
are doing here is a secure way of
running a SQL query in the jdbc using a
parameterized statement Define which
user we want to find so there's a string
the email comes in connection to the
database we are going to figure out how
the connection is going to be passed how
it is going to be created construct the
SQL statement we want to run specifying
the parameter right so we Define how is
it going to be uh created what is going
to be created what can be passed to the
database and what should not be passed
to the database so that is one way of
utilizing prepaid statements and
parameterized queries
then we have object relational mapping
most development teams prefer to use
objection object relational mapping
Frameworks to evake the translation of
SQL results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping
where we map certain objects
and allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs in a simple way to
protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of code
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are
they're feeded or well application and
they never reach the database other
methods of preventing SQL injection are
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use
oauth or some other service for a single
sign-on mechanism does you rely on a
third party
to maintain the security of
authentication and what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the
authentication mechanisms to third
parties such as Facebook or Google
because they understand that that
authentication mechanism is as safe as
can be Facebook and Google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of Security
Experts and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is Top Notch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly for SQL injection attacks is
one of the Sure Shot method of
mitigating or minimizing the threat in
the first place so at this point in time
you have realized that the application
has some vulnerabilities for SQL
injection and instead of recoding or
restructuring the application uh you
want to take the easier way out or the
cheaper way out so what you do is you
you install a web application firewall
and you configure the web application
firewall to identify malicious queries
and stop them at the firewall level
itself so they never reach the
application and thus the vulnerabilities
on the application don't get executed
buy better software
and I'll keep on updating the software
so it's not necessary that once you have
a software you install it it's going to
be safe for Life new vulnerabilities are
discovered every day every hour and it
may so happen what is secure today
may be completely insecure tomorrow or
the day after right so you need to keep
on upgrading the software if there are
no upgrades available and the volume it
is still exists you might want to
migrate to a better software and thus
ensure that you don't get hacked right
always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you're getting and based on those
queries you want to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are creating uh are
not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have if you want to
kick start your career as a cyber
security professional in six months then
try giving a show to Simply learn
skeltex cyber security Bootcamp The
Bootcamp link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the Boot Camp Page where you can find
a complete overview of The Bootcamp
being offered and now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who've
experienced massive success in their
careers by opting out for these courses
start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's perspective
cross-site scripting also known as xss
is a type of code injection attack that
occurs on the client side the attacker
intends to run harmful scripts in the
victim's web browser by embedding
malicious code in a genuine webpage or
online application
the real Attack takes place when the
victim hits the malicious code infected
web page or online application
the web page or application serves as a
vehicle for the malicious script to be
sent to the user's browser forums
message boards and online pages that
enable comments are vulnerable vehicles
that are frequently utilized for
cross-scripting assaults
a web feature web application is
vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then pass this
user input
in vbscript ActiveX Flash and even CSS
cross-site scripting attacks are
conceivable they are nevertheless most
ubiquitous in JavaScript going to the
fact that JavaScript is most important
to most browser experiences nowadays
the main purpose of this attack is to
steal the other user's identity be it
via cookies session tokens and other
information
in most of the cases this attack is
being used to steal the other person's
cookies
as we know cookies help us to log in
automatically therefore with the stolen
cookies we can log in with other
identities and this is one of the
reasons why this attack is considered as
one of the riskiest attacks it can be
performed with different client-side
programming languages as well
cross-site scripting is often compared
with similar client set attacks as
client-side languages are mostly being
used during this however an xss attack
is considered riskier because of its
ability to damage even less vulnerable
Technologies
most often this attack is performed with
JavaScript and HTML JavaScript is a
programming language that runs on web
pages inside your browser the
client-side code add functionality and
interactivity to the web page and is
used extensively on all major
applications and CMS platforms unlike
server-side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
Navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window
while JavaScript is client-side and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously
the manner of attack can range in a
variety of ways it can be a single link
which the user must click on to initiate
a JavaScript piece of code it can be
used to show any piece of images that
can be later used as a front-end for
malicious code being installed as
malware
but the majority of Internet users
unaware of how metadata works or the
ways in which web requests are called
the chances of victims clicking on a
redirecting links is far too high
cross-site scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the client
side using a fake page or even a form
that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim
these attacks occur when the malicious
user finds the vulnerable parts of the
website and sends it as appropriate
malicious input
now that we understand the basics of
cross-site scripting let us learn more
about how this kind of attack works
the first place we have the website or
the web browser which is used to show
content to the victim or which is the
user in our case
whenever the user wants to grab some
content from the website the website
asks the data from the server the server
provides this information to the website
and the web browser which ultimately
resists the victim
how the hacker comes into play here
it passes on certain arguments to the
web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways depending on the type of
attack the malicious script may be
reflected on the victim's browser but
stored in the database and executed
every time when the user calls the
appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output
a malicious user can enter a script
which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not
therefore this malicious script is being
executed on the victim's browser or any
faked form if that is being displayed
for the users
there are many ways to trigger an
exercise attack for example the
execution could be triggered
automatically when the page loads or
when I use a hovers over specific
elements of the page like hyperlinks
potential consequences of cross-site
scripting attacks include capturing
keystrokes of a user redirecting a user
to malicious websites running web
browser-based exploits obtaining cookie
information of a user who is logged into
a website and many more in some cases
cross-site scripting attack leads to
complete compromise of the victims
account attackers can trick users into
entering credentials on a fake form
which can then provide all information
to the attacker
with the basic working of a cross-site
scripting attack out of the way let us
go over the different ways hackers can
leverage vulnerable web applications to
gather information and eventually Bridge
those systems
the prime purpose of Performing exercise
attack is to steal the other person's
identity
as mentioned it may be cookies session
tokens Etc
xss may also be used to display fixed
Pages or forms for the victim however
this can be performed in several ways
we have a reflected attack this attack
occurs when a malicious script is not
being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected xss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result
the attack code can be included in the
faked URL or in the HTTP parameters it
can affect the victim in different ways
by displaying fake malicious speech or
by sending a malicious email
in a reflected cross-site scripting
example the input of a search form is
reflected on the page to show what the
search key was an attacker May crafter
URL that contains malicious code and
then spread the same URL via email or
social media a user who clicks on this
link opens the valid web application
which then runs the malicious code in
the browser this script is not stored in
the web application and malicious code
is shown only to one user the user that
opens the link executes the strip and
the attack is not necessarily visible on
the server side or to the app owner
itself
the next variant is a stored cross-site
scripting attacks
this occurs when a malicious script is
being saved on the web server
permanently
this can be considered a riskier attack
since it has leveraged for more damage
in this type of attack the malicious
code or script is being saved on the
server for example in the database of
the website it is executed every time
the users call the appropriate
functionality
this way stored xss attack can affect
many users
also as the script is being stored on
the web server it will affect the
website for a longer time
in order to perform stored xss attack
the malicious scripts should be sent
through the vulnerable input form for
example can be a comment field or review
field
in this way the appropriate script will
be saved in the database and evaluated
on the page load or appropriate function
calling
in a stored xss example the script might
have been submitted by an input field to
the web server which did not perform a
sufficient validation and stores the
script permanently in the database
the consequence of this might be that
this script is now being delivered to
all users visiting the web application
and if for example able to gain access
to the user session cookies
in this attack the script is permanently
stored in the web app the users visiting
the app after the information retrieve
the script
the malicious code then exploits the
flaws in the web application and the
script and the attack is visible on the
server side or to the app owner as well
the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks
this type of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client-side code does not change
when the Dom environment is being
modified in the victim's browser the
client-side code executes differently
in order to get a better understanding
of how xss Dom attack is being performed
let us analyze the following example if
there is a website called texting.com we
know default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform exercise Dom attack we
should send a script as parameters
a Dom based exercise attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client-side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree or the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be executed
the malicious quote the exploits flaws
in the browser on the user side and the
script and the attack is not necessarily
visible on the server side or to the app
owner
by now it is clear that cross-site
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of fails one
can Safeguard against such attacks let's
go through some of these preventive
measures
like mentioned earlier xss attacks are
sometimes difficult to detect
however this can be changed if you get
some external help
a way to prevent xss attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
security suit or akinetic security suit
still manual testing is highly time
consuming and costly and therefore not
possible to be done for every iteration
of your web application
consequently your code shouldn't be
untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-site
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that a web
application slide version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature
input fields are the most common point
of entry for xss attack script therefore
you should always screen and validate
any information input into data fields
this is particularly important if the
data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected xss attacks
validation should occur on both the
client side and server side as an added
precaution
the cells validating the data before
it's being sent to the servers and can
also protect against persistent xss
Scripts
this can be accomplished using
JavaScript
exercise attacks only appear if any user
input is being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible
if you need to display user data
restrict the places where the user input
might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against excessive
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page
rather than trying to determine if the
data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and Escape data whether it is user
provided or not unfortunately because
there are many different rules for
escaping you still must choose the
proper type of escaping before settling
on a final code
encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context
sometimes you'll need to apply multiple
layers of encoding in the correct order
for example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encoded
content security policy or CSP is a
computer security standard introduced to
prevent cross-site scripting click
checking and other code injection
attacks resulting from the execution of
malicious content in The Trusted web
page context
it is a candidate recommendations of the
w3c working group on a web application
security
it's widely supported by modern web
browsers and provides a standard method
for website owners to declare approved
origins of content the browser should be
allowed to load on their website
HTTP only is an additional flag included
in a set cookie HTTP response header
using the HTTP only flag when generating
a cookie helps mitigate the risk of
client-side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client-side script again this is if the
browser supports the select
as a result even if a cross-site
scripting flow exists and a user
accidentally accesses a link that
exploits this flow the browser will not
reveal the cookie to a third party
if a browser does not support HTTP only
and a website attempts to set an HTTP
only cookie the HTTP only flag will be
ignored browser browser thus creating a
traditional script accessible cookie as
a result the cookie becomes vulnerable
to theft of modification by any
malicious script
next on our docket is a live
demonstration where we solve a set of
cross-site scripting problems starting
from the basic level to the topmost
level 6. we're going to start at level
1.
in this web application it demonstrates
a common cause of cross-site scripting
where user input is directly included in
the page without proper escaping
if you interact with a vulnerable
application window here and find a way
to make it execute JavaScript of our
chosen
we can take actions inside the
vulnerable window or directly edit its
URL bar
this task needs only basic knowledge
let's see why the most primitive
injections work here right away
let's do a simple query and inspect the
resulting HTML page
I am going to use this phrase
with a single quote as a special
character
we can now inspect the HTML page
we can see here in this line
the special character single quote
appears in the result over here
the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the
preload should be included in the URL to
perform successful exploitation
we can use any payload but we're going
to use the simple one to perform an
alert in this web application it's
simple and can be shown easily
we're just going to write the script
over here
and we're going to press search
as you can see we have successfully
launched our first cross-site scripting
attack we can see an alert box pop-up
with the necessary message and a similar
process can be used to steal browser
cookies and passwords albeit with
different commands
now we have the option to move to level
2.
in this web application it shows that
how easily xss bugs can be introduced in
complex chat applications
chat app conversations are stored in a
database and retrieved when a user wants
to see the conversation therefore if a
malicious user injects some JavaScript
code all visitors will be infected this
kind of cross-site scripting attack is
more powerful
and it is more riskier than reflected
cross-site scripting attacks and that's
why is known as stored xss
I posted my query
with a special character of a single
quote
and this is what I get
whatever I typed in simply appeared on
the page right after I click on share
status
let's see the source
you can see here the text I posted seems
directly put inside a block code tag so
even a simple script tag we used in
level 1 should work here but it will not
let us examine the code to understand
why
we're going to toggle the code away here
and check the index.html file
important part
is line 32.
the generated HTML fragment which is the
HTML variable in the code is added to
the mail HTML using the inner HTML
method
so when the browser passing this HTML
fragment it will not execute any script
tag defined within that HTML fragment
HTML parser will not execute a script
tag when it passes htmls via this method
this is why the script tag like we used
in level 1 is not going to work here our
solution is to use events events will
execute the defined javascripts
we're going to use an image over here
and when we press on share status
in the above injection we are loading an
image that doesn't exist which causes to
trigger an on error event
an honor event the it will execute our
alert method
with that we are able to beat level 2
and we can now move up to the next level
in our challenge
as you can see clicking on any tab
causes the tab number to be displayed in
the URL fragment
this hints that the value after the
hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable
to confirm let's analyze the code
as you can see in line 43 inside the
event handling
the value provided after the hash in the
URL
is directly passed onto the two tab
method no input validation is being
performed
the value passed to the two-step method
is directly injected into the IMG tag in
line 17.
this is an unsafe assignment and it is
the vulnerable part of the code
now all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript
remember the script tag from Level 1
would not work here since the variable
HTML is used to add the Dom dynamically
hence the events are Aces here once
again
I will choose to use the existing IMG
tag and change the source to something
that doesn't exist hence forcing it to
fall into execute an on error even which
I will pass the URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java pop-up has opened up here with
the same message of exercise level 3 has
been completed
but this we can now move on to level
four which is going to present a
different kind of attack
in this web application there is a timer
on the page that means whatever numbers
we put in the Box a countdown starts and
then when it finishes the application
alerts
that the countdown is finished
and we can see the time is up appearing
over here and this resets the timer
again
now it is obvious that the value entered
in the text box is transferred to the
server over the timer parameter in the
URL
let us examine the code to see how the
timer parameter is being handled
going to visit timer.html over here
and we're going to check over here
in line 21
the start timer method is being called
in the onload event
however the timer parameter is being
directly passed to the start timer
method
we need to perform a pop-up Alert in the
web application which escapes the
content of the function start timer
without making the JavaScript code
the parameter value is directly added to
the start timer method without any
filtering what we can try to do here is
to inject an alert function to be
executed inside the online event along
with the start timer method
we're going to remove this argument
and put a script over here
now when we press on create timer
and we have a pop-up with exercise level
4 completed
it can now move on to level 5.
in this web application this application
xss is different because this challenge
description says cross-site scripting
isn't just about correctly escaping data
sometimes attackers can do bad things
even without injecting new elements into
the Dom it's kind of open redirect
because the attack payload is executed
as a result of modifying the Dom
environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the
client-side code runs in an unexpected
manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the sign up page
is inspector
the href attribute value of next link is
confer which is exactly the value of the
next URL query parameter
as you can see over here this means
using the next query parameter can be
used to inject a JavaScript code to the
href attribute of the next link
the following is the best way to do it
as soon as the user clicks on the link
the script will be triggered
foreign
that we had provided in the URL as a
parameter to the next variable
since the value of next provided appears
on a pop-up we can consider the
attacker's success and move on to the
final level 6.
in this web application it shows some of
the external Javascript is received
if you analyze the URL
you can see that the script is loaded
already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles the value after the hashtag
if you check on line 45 the value right
after the hashtag
is taken as the gadget name
and then in line 48
the value is directly passed on to the
include Gadget method
another include Gadget method that we
can see over here
you can see in line 18
a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line 28.
this means we can completely control the
source attribute of the script tag that
is being created
that is with this vulnerability we can
inject our own JavaScript file into the
code
we can inject the URL of our own hosted
JavaScript into the web applications URL
after the hashtag and the URL should not
be using https but anything like that to
bypass the regular expression for
security checking
going to remove the pre-store URL
and we're going to load our own
Javascript file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge
we completed six different varieties of
cross scripting attacks and use
different solutions for all of the six
questions with work from home being the
norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a
DDOS attack
these DDOS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botnet farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020. lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DDOS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botnets allow further penetration into
the consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems
GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DDOS
attack in 2018. widely suspected to be
conducted by Chinese authorities this
attack went on for about 20 minutes
after which the systems were brought
into a stable condition it was the
strongest leaders attack to date at the
time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation DDOS attacks are still
at large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space
hey everyone this is Baba from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is Adidas attack let's learn more about
what is a DDOS attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or DDOS is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered
this can be achieved by thwarting access
to virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications
in a Dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
detos attack comes from multiple systems
generally these attacks work by Drowning
a system with requests for data this
could be sending a web server so many
requests to serve a page that it crashes
under the demand or it could be a
database being hit with a high volume of
queries the result is available internet
bandwidth CPU and RAM capacity become
overwhelmed
the impact could range from a minor
annoyance from disrupted services to
experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center
the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DDOS
campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how DDOS attack work
Adidas attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices
simply put a vast network of computers
are hacked via malware ransomware or
just simple social engineering
these devices become a part of the
botnet which can be triggered anytime to
start bombarding a system or a server on
the instruction of the hacker that
created the botnet
the devices in this networks are called
Bots or zombies
in the second phase a particular Target
is selected for the attack
when the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests the target
thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth
these can be simple ping requests or
complex attacks like SYM flooding and
UDP flooding the aim is to overwhelm
them with more traffic than the server
or the network can accommodate the goal
is to render the website or service
inoperable
there is a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of DDOS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DDOS
attacks
volume based attacks use massive amounts
of bogus traffic to overwhelm a resource
it can be a website or a server
they include icmp UDF and spoofed packet
flood attacks
the size of volume based attack is
measured in bits per second
these attacks focus on clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warranty reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate users
next we have the protocol level attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balances and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the DDOS attacks
these protocol attacks include syn
floods and Smurf DDOS among others and
the size is measured in packets per
second
for example in an SSL handshake server
replies to the Hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the IP is poofed and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgment without any end in sight
finally we have the application Level
attacks application attacks are
conducted by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests the size of
application layer attacks is measured in
requests per second
these are relatively sophisticated
attacks that Target the application and
operating system level vulnerabilities
they prevent the specific applications
from delivering necessary information to
users and Hawk the network bandwidth up
to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are HTTP
flooding and bgp hijacking a single
device can request data from a server
using HTTP post or get without any
issues
however when the requisite botnet is
instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and unusable
but what about the reasons for such an
attack there are multiple lines of
thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DDOS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive advantage
many DDOS attacks are conducted by
hacking communities against rival groups
some organizations hire such communities
to stagger their Rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field
since being a victim of a detours attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these DDOS
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom
the resources are jammed and the only
way to clear the way is if the target
company agrees to pay a designated
amount of money to the hackers even a
few minutes of inactivity is detrimental
to a company's reputation in the global
market and it can cause a spiral effect
both in terms of market value and
product security index most of the time
a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while
tdos attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use redos attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
forum
primarily political these attacks also
focus on online communities ethical
dilemmas or even protests against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against DDOS attacks
the company can employ load balances and
firewalls to help protect the data from
such attacks load balances reroute the
traffic from one server to another in a
DDOS attack this reduces the single
point of failure and adds resiliency to
the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic
indoor system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a DDOS attack in action
early detection of a DDOS attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event
once you've detected the attack you will
have to find a way to respond for
example you will have to work on
dropping the malicious DDOS traffic
before it teaches your server so that it
doesn't throttle and exhaust your
bandwidth here's where you will filter
the traffic so that only legitimate
traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by a cluster
resources
the most important stage in DDOS
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of readers attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
Cloud providers like Amazon web services
and Microsoft Azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DDOS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased tdos
attacks
additionally reputable Cloud providers
of our Network redundancy duplicating
copies of your data systems and
equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DDOS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a Beat
one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted
since tdos attacks fundamentally operate
on the principle of overwhelming systems
with heavy traffic simply provisioning
extra bandwidth to handle unexpected
traffic spikes can provide a measure of
protection
this solution can prove expensive as a
lot of that bandwidth is going to go
unused most of the time
a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boosts
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates DDOS attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular cdns include
Akamai CDN cloudflare AWS cloudfront Etc
let's start with our demo regarding the
effects of DDOS attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a dose
attack of sorts
once a botnet is ready multiple devices
can do the same and eventually emulate a
DDOS attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parrot security operating system
running
for a Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use Wireshark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly
this is Linux like which is a target
machine and this is parrot security
which is used by the hacker when trying
to launch a DDOS attack this is just one
of the distros that can be used
to launch the attack we must first find
the IP address of our Target
so to find the IP address we open the
terminal
we use the command ifconfig
and here we can find the IP address
now remember we're launching this attack
in VMware now the both the instances of
parrot security and Linux light are
being run on my local network so the
address that you can see here is
192.168.72.129 which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi
when launching attacks with public
servers or public addresses it will have
a public IP address that does not belong
to the 192.168 subnet
once we have the IP address
we can use a tool called
hp3
hp3 is an open source packet generator
and analyzer for the TCP protocol
to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using Wireshark
is a network traffic analyzer we can see
whatever traffic that is passing through
the Linux light distro is being
displayed over here with the IP address
the source IP and the destination IP as
to where the request is being
transferred to
once we have the Dos attack launched you
can see the results coming over here
from The Source IP which will be parrot
security Now to launch the hp3 command
we need to give sudo access to the
console which is the root access
now we have the root access for the
console
the hp3 command will have a few
arguments to go with it which are as you
can see on the screen
minus s and a flood
a hyphen V
hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is 192.168 72.129
in this command we have a few arguments
such as the minus s which specifies syn
packets like in an SSL handshake we have
the syn request that the client sends to
the server to initiate a connection
The Hyphen flood aims to ignore the
reply is that the server will send back
to the client in response to the syn
packets here the parrot security OS is
the client and Linux slide being the
server
minus v stands for verbosity as in where
we will see some output when the
requests are being sent
The Hyphen p80 stands for Port 80 which
you can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port
and finally we have the IP address of
our Target
as of right now if we check Wireshark it
is relatively clear and there is no
indication of a DDOS attack incoming now
once we launch the attack over here
we can see the requests coming in from
this IP which is
192.168 72.128
till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux light
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the http
flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down
now remember Linux light is a distro
that can focus on that serves as a
backend
now remember Linux light is a distro and
such Linux distros are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack
now the system has become completely
irresponsive this has happened due to
the huge number of requests that came
from Pilot security
you can see whatever I press nothing is
responded even the Wireshark has stopped
capturing new requests because the CPU
usage right now is completely 100 and at
this point of time anyone who is trying
to request some information from this
Linux distro or where this Linux this
row is being used as a backend for a
server or a database cannot access
anything else the system has completely
stopped responding and any request any
legitimate request from legitimate users
will be dropped
once you stop the attack over here it
takes a bit of time to settle down
remember it's still out of control but
eventually the traffic dies down and the
system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into
that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
Adidas attack comes into play what we
did right now is a Dos attack as in a
single system is being used to penetrate
a Target server using a single request
now
when a DDOS attack multiple systems such
as multiple pilot security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and inoperable
as a final note we would like to remind
that this is for educational purposes
only and we do not endorse any attacks
on any proven domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack
a Brute Force are known as Brute Force
cracking is the Cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your keyring and
eventually finding the right one Force
attacks are simple and reliable there is
no prior knowledge needed about the
victim to start an attack most of the
systems falling prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until the final
one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great deal although with enough time
and resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is Baba from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack
let's begin with learning about Rufus
attacks in detail
a Brute Force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
Network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
Brute Force attacks while the attacker
already has a list of usernames and
passwords that need to be stretched
against the target it doesn't need to
create any other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute forcing a system let's
learn about each of them in detail
in Step 1 we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing there are some popular names on
the market like hashcat
Hydra
and John the Ripper
while each of them has its own strength
and weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like Kali Linux and
parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved and
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process
let's say the hacker is aware of the
password being a specific eight digit
word containing only letters and symbols
this will substantially increase the
chances of being able to guess the right
password since we remove the time taken
to generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken we can try and
break into a specific encrypted document
a social media account or even devices
at home that connect to the internet
let's say there is a Wi-Fi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and The Brute Force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely lead to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
Brute Force Works let's see if we can
answer this question
we learned about how complex passwords
are tougher to crack by Brute Force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using Brute
Force tools leave your answers in the
comment section and we will get back to
you with the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
Brute Force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to single device which belongs to
the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP Etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims since the
hack machines all have different IP
addresses and Mac addresses it becomes
challenging to trace the spam back to
the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a boot Force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such let's learn
about some of the ways we can prevent
ourselves from becoming a victim of
Brute Force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of its standing Brute Force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or a
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed this OTB can be obtained either
via email SMS or specific 2fa
applications like authi and Aegis
email and SMS based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which SIM cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa Cores are much more reliable and
secure
captures are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website
since Brute Force tools are automated
forcing the hacker to solve captcha for
every iteration of a password manually
is very challenging the capture system
can filter out these automated Bots that
keep refreshing the page with different
credentials thereby reducing the chances
of Brute Force considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent Brute Force attempts many
websites lock account for 30 minutes
after three failed password attempts to
secure the account against any such
attack and an additional note some
websites also send an email instructing
the user that there have been three
insecure attempts to log into the
website
let's look at a demonstration of how
Brute Force attacks work in a real world
situation
the world has gone Wireless with Wi-Fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate
to further test the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks we will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen you
first need to capture a handshake file
which is a connection file from the
Wi-Fi router to a connecting device like
a mobile or a laptop
the operating system used for this
process is pilot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
start a demo we're going to use a tool
called air Garden which is made to hack
into wireless network specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into a Wi-Fi and to capture the
handshake file we're going to need an
external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in managed mode right now
so we're going to select option 2 which
is to put the interface in monitor mode
and its name is now wlan0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary Json why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cards that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
with the first step we have to explore
for targets and it is written that
monitor mode is necessary to select a
Target so let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio 24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi's this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices
those channels features on one or two or
there are some many channels that the
networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the MAC address of the
device that is connected to a router
this basis ID is supposed to be which
wi-fi it is connected to for example
5895 d8
is this one
which is the jio 24 router so we already
know which router has a device connected
to it and we can use our attack to
capture this handshake
now that we it has already ran for one
minute now that we press Ctrl C
we will be asked to select a Target see
it has already selected the number five
which is the jio 24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select Network 5
and we run our capture handshake
it says we have a valid WPA WPA2 Network
Target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a Dior air replay
attack
what this attack does is kick the
clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the dioc air replay
attack
select a timeout value let's say we give
it 60 Seconds
and we start the script
we can see it capturing data from the
jio 24 Network and here we go
we have the WPA handshake files
once the handshake file is captured you
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a peak MK
ID from the target network has
successfully been captured this is the
file that is already stored
the chart cap file for the path we can
let's say we can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated
we can already see
a Target over here same jio 24 router
with the BSS ID
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline WPA WP to
decrypt menu
since you'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option 1
now to run the Brute Force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
air crack or we can go with the hashcad
let's go with lcac plus crunch which is
a Brute Force attack against a handshake
file we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the dssid is the one which denotes the
jio 24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA to psk key
will always be more than 8 digits and
Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits you can go with
the minimum length as 10. and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as 20.
the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to Brute
Force for example if we already know
that or we have seen a user use a
password while connecting to the router
as something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option seven
and it's going to start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits are a
it starts working its way from the end
from the last character it keeps trying
every single combination you can see the
last the fourth character from the right
side the D it will eventually turn to E
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out since
the handshake file is encrypted using
the security key that is the WPA to key
of the router whichever passphrase is
able to decrypt the handshake key
completely will be the key of the Wi-Fi
router this is the way we can Brute
Force into Wi-Fi routers anywhere in the
world cyber attacks are frequently
making headlines in today's digital
environment at any time everyone who
uses a computer could become a victim of
a Cyber attack
there are various thoughts of cyber
attacks ranging from phishing to
password attacks in this video we'll
look into one such attack that is known
as botnet but before we begin if you
love watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon never
to miss an update to begin with let's
take a look at some of the famous potent
attacks
the first one is Mirai botnet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots that on
command perform basic and medium level
denial of service attacks
then we have the Zeus bot specifically
designed for attacking the system for
Bank related information and data now
let's see what exactly a botnet is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious quotes known as
malware
each of these infected devices are known
as Bots the hijacked criminal known as
bot hoarder remotely controls them the
Bots are used to automate large scale
attacks including Data Theft
server failure malware propagation
and denial of service attacks
now that we know what exactly a button
it is let's dive deeper into learning
how botnet works
during the preparation of a bottleneck
Network the first step involves
preparing the botnet Army after that the
connection between the botnet Army and
the control server established and the
end the launching of the attack is
turned by the bot hoarder let's
understand through our illustration
firstly we have a bot order that
initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system let's see some
details regarding the preparation of the
botnet army
the first step is known as the prepping
the botnet army the first step is
creating a botnet is to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that there are enough Bots to
carry out the attack
this way it creates Bots either by
exploiting the security gaps in the
software or websites or using phishing
attacks they are often deployed through
Trojan horses
for the next step we have
establishing the connection
once it hacks the device as per previous
step it infects it with a specific
malware that connects the device back to
the control bottom server a bot herder
uses command programming to drive the
bot's actions
and the last step is known as launching
the attack once infected a bot allows
access to admin level operation like
Gathering and stealing of data reading
and rewriting the system data monitoring
user activities performing denial of
service attacks including other cyber
crimes
now let's take a look at the important
architecture
the first type is known as client server
model the client server model is a
traditional model that operates with the
help of a command and control center
server and communication protocols like
IRC
when the bot order issues a command to
the server it is then relayed to the
clients to perform malicious actions
then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the parts are topological
interconnected and acts as both CNC
servers that is the server and decline
today hackers adopt this approach to
avoid detection and single point failure
in the end we will see some points on
some counter measure against botnet
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates
after that we should avoid clicking
random pop-ups or links that we often
see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware software's and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack the internet is
an endless source of information and
data still in some cases we come across
some occurrences like cyber attacks
hacking force entry which may affect a
Time on the web
hi everyone and welcome to the simpleton
Channel today we will discuss a topic
that secretly records our input data
that is known as e-loggers but before we
begin if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
to understand the key logging problem
better let's take a look at an example
this is June she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is Jacob from the information
Department who is here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems a system was
facing with which included slow reaction
speed and unusual internet activity
as Jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems a system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we learn what exactly
keyloggers are and how they affect our
system what are the harmful effects that
key logging can bring into the system to
begin with we learn what exactly the key
logging program is
as the name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file then the same program
secretly sends these log files to its
origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into a system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind a key logging issue entering into
the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of key
logging program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then there are cases when the system
freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about this could lead to the
identification of a problem into the
system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is API based the most common key logging
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and locks it
then we have form grabbing based
keyloggers as the name suggests they are
a best key loggers that store the form
data that is if we often use waveforms
or different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its origin
then we have kernel based keyloggers
these key loggers are installed deeply
into the operating system where they can
hide from different antivirus if not
checked properly and they record the
data that we type on the keyboard and
send it to its origin
and lastly we have Hardware Key loggers
these key loggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
now let's take a look how hack is
differentiate different type of recorded
data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
Secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
keyloggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the key login issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that installed a particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent a system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input are sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related different
websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the system
which is
this Library
now we will run it
the system says the library is already
installed into the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
Library
from this Library we will import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now from the same we'll also import
key module
and The Listener module
and also
the logging module which will help us to
record the data into a log file
for the next part
we'll write a piece of code that will
allow us to save the data that is
recorded by the program into our text
file that will be named as key
underscore log text file along with the
date and time stamp let's take a look
now
we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
g-log Dot txt file
and also through the part where the
format of the data is recorded
we put the brackets over here
contain the file name now we will write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given as
the format would be the message and the
timestamp which would be given as
along with
the timestamp
giving us percentage
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we will Design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while press function
would be a function that will come into
play when the keyboard key has been
pressed
is
and
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and
login
the Press key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the log file
now
we'll design a function that is while
release
that will come into play
when
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to Loop these functions that is
while press and while release to
continue its cycle
that will be going for
file
press
and
on
release will contain while release
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads and
store them into the log file
now that we have completed the code for
the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
no
to verify the program let's open Notepad
and on the notepad
we'll write
hello world
which will be the basic whether the
program is working or not let's take a
look
and we will go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here we see the key log text that
is a text file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data that is
created
as we started with node
then this is a Hello World part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly
now that we have reached the end of the
module let's take a look at the summary
firstly we learn what exactly key
loggers are
then we understood what different modes
are present how the system get infected
with the key logging problem then we
learned how to detect the problem into
our system then we learn what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net
we also understood how hackers use the
recorded data from the program and we
also learned whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system and before we begin if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or
to become an ethical hacker by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who only sits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts and
driving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT Schwartzman
College of computing the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
before we learn about the Pegasus
platform let us understand what spyware
is and it's working spyware is a
category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread malicious links via email
or chat applications when a link with
the malware is received clicking on this
link will activate the spyware which
allows the hacker to spy on all our user
information
but some spyware systems even clicking
on the link isn't necessary to trigger
the malicious payload
this can ultimately cause security
complications and further loss of
privacy
one such spyware system that is making
the rounds in the tech industry today is
Pegasus the Pegasus is a spyware system
developed by an Israeli company known as
the NSO group it runs on mainly mobile
devices spanning across the major
operating systems like the Apple's IOS
on iPhone and the standard Android
versions this is not a newly developed
platform since Pegasus has existed since
as early as 2016. a highly intricate
spyware program that can track user
location read text messages scan through
mobile files access device camera and
microphone to record voice and video
Pegasus has all the tools necessary to
enforce surveillance for any client that
wishes to buy its services initially the
NSO group had designed the software to
be used against terrorist factions of
the world with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on
eventually the primary clients became
Sovereign Nations spying on Public
Information that is supposed to stay
private became really easy with this
service
multiple devices can be affected with
the same spyware system to create a
network information this network keeps
feeding data to the host to understand
how a network can be created let's know
how a mobile device can be affected by
Pegasus
we all communicate with friends and
family over instant messaging
applications and email in some instances
if you check her inbox on a regular
basis you must have noticed that we
received some spam emails that the mail
providers like Gmail and Yahoo can just
filter into the spam folder some of
these messages bypass this filter and
make their way into a person's inbox
they look like January emails which are
supposed to be safe the Pegasus spyware
targets such occurrences bypassing
malicious messages and links which
install the necessary Spy software on
the user's mobile device be it Android
or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS Stacks WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threema once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does
Pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes through
the device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex spyware software like
Pegasus can access the root files on our
mobiles these root files hold
information that is crucial to the
working of the Android and iOS operating
systems leaking such private information
is a massive blow to the security and
the privacy of an individual the
information that may seem trivial like
the name of your Wi-Fi connection or the
last time you ordered an item from
Amazon are indeed all valuable
information this exploitation is
primarily possible due to the zero day
vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits
these exploits are then sent to innocent
users with a link or a message like we
had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality
these become the Gateway for spyware to
enter into the system
you can never be 100 safe but you sure
can give it all in protecting yourself
the one thing where Pegasus stands out
is that zero click action feature
usually in spam emails the malicious
code is activated when the user clicks
the malware link a user doesn't need to
click the link in the new version of the
Pegasus and a few other spyware programs
once the message arrives in the inbox of
WhatsApp Gmail or any other chat
applications the spyware gets activated
and everything can be recorded and sent
back to the central server the primary
issue with being affected by spyware as
a victim is detection
unlike crypto Miners and Trojans spying
Services usually do not demand many
system resources which makes them tough
to detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of Performance
Set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longevity by
the users they do not check meticulously
for any other causes that is causing the
Slowdown
when left unchecked these devices can
capture voice and video from the mobile
sensors while keeping the owner in the
dark let's take a moment to check if we
are well aware of the causes of such
attacks how do users fall prey to such
spyware programs a by installing
untested software B by clicking on the
third party links from email and
messages
see by not keeping their apps and phones
updated or deep all of the above let us
know your answers in the comment section
below and we will revive the correct
answer next week but what about the
unaffected devices the vulnerable ones
while we cannot be certain of our
security there are a few things we can
do to boost our device
beat against Pegasus or the next big
spyware on the market
let's say we are safe now and we have
the time to take the necessary steps to
prevent a spyware attack what are the
things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated with the latest security patches
the vulnerabilities that the exploits
Target are often discovered by
developers from Google and apple which
send the security patches quickly this
can be done for individual apps as well
so keeping them updated is of utmost
importance
while the most secure devices have
fallen prey to Pegasus as well a
security patch from developers may help
in minimizing the damage at a later
stage or maybe negate the entire spyware
platform altogether another big factor
is the spread of malware is the trend of
side loading Android applications using
dot APK files downloading such apps from
a third-party website have no security
checks involved and are mostly
responsible for adware and spyware
Innovations on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
media they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into a
device you should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains
spyware is a controversial segment in
governance while the ramifications are
pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veil of democracy
altogether
even if our daily life is rather
simplistic we must understand that
privacy is not about what we have to
hide instead it portrays the things we
have to protect it stands for everything
we have to share with the outside world
both rhetorically and literally hey
everyone today we look at the hack which
took the World by storm and affected
multiple governments and corporations
the solarwinds attack
the global statistics indicate that
upward of 18 000 customers have been
affected potentially needing billions to
recover the losses incurred before we
have a look at this hack Make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
notification Bell to never miss an
update from simpler
the date is December 8 2020. if I arai a
global leader in companies specializing
in cyber security released a blog post
that caught the attention of the entire
IIT Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solarwinds
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat
the breach was estimated to be running
since the spring of 2020 and when
virtually unnoticed for months the
reveals sent the developers of the Orion
software into a frenzy as they quickly
released a couple of hot fixes for their
platform in order to mitigate this
threat and prevent further damage but
how did this come into existence
you first need to understand the
platform which was responsible for this
breach solo wins a software company
based in Texas United States had
developed a management platform known as
Orion catering to corporations and
governments worldwide Ryan was
responsible for the monitoring and
management of it Administration this
included managing the client's servers
virtualization components and even the
organization's Network infrastructure
that bought the platform
solarwinds claims they have more than
300 000 clients including U.S government
agencies and several Fortune 500
companies this entire chain can be
classified as a supply chain attack in
this variant of cyber crime the hackers
Target relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferability
services rendered by a third party since
there is no direct jurisdiction over it
in this case the Orion platform was the
primary target the culprit however was
software updates the update server for
solarwinds Orion had a malicious version
attached with malware or a Trojan to be
precise this was made possible since the
code repository that handled the
software updates was breached once the
update server repository was compromised
the source code of the applications
became open to modification and
malicious code found its way onto the
software a remote access Trojan was
attached to a potential update nicknamed
the Sunburst update this update gave
hackers backdoor access to any client
that uses the correct version on its
release many clients believe the update
to be legitimate since it came from the
right source and they had no reason to
believe otherwise
American government agencies were
supposedly hit the hardest as the list
of victims included the U.S departments
of Homeland Security treasury and health
several private companies like Cisco
Nvidia and Intel were compromised
according to a list published by the
cyber security firm through sec
most of the companies had issues quick
updates to fix this vulnerabilities
introduced by the software while the
actual perpetrators have never been
found it is believed that this was an
act of cross-border corporate Espionage
conducted by state-sponsored hackers
either from Russia or China
before we move forward let's take a
recap of the things we learned
category of malware was responsible for
the solarwinds hack was it one a virus a
remote access Trojan a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach
there are a couple of things that we as
consumers must always tend to when
working our way through the World Wide
Web
using a password manager is highly
recommended which can generate secure
alphanumeric passwords you must also use
different passwords for different
accounts thereby reducing the chances of
a single point of failure should one of
those accounts get breached usage of
two-factor authentication applications
is also encouraged since it acts as a
safety net if hackers directly get a
hold of our credentials
clicking on unknown links transmitted
via emails is also a strict no as is
installing applications from unverified
sources the solarwinds hack is estimated
to cost the payment company nearly 18
million dollars as reparations making it
one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history
as recently as of July 2021 the hackers
access some U.S attorneys Microsoft 365
email accounts as part of the attack
criminal organizations like the FBI and
CIA are determined to figure out the
culprits responsible for this debacle
however the intricacy and the full
extent of the breach makes it a way more
complicated job if you want to
kick-start your career as a cyber
security professional in six months then
try giving a show to Simply learn
skeltex cyber security boot camp the
boot camp link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the Boot Camp Page where you can find
a complete overview of the boot camp
being offered and now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
experienced massive success in their
careers by opting out for these courses
being offered during data transmission
there are various external factors which
can affect the transmission of data over
a network channel
to prevent such cases from happening we
use Internet Protocol security which
we'll be discussing in the session on
ipsec explain
hi guys and welcome to the internet at
first thing we do by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to miss an update from
us
now without further Ado let's take a
look at the agenda for this session
to begin with we will look into what is
ipsec
continuing with why do we use ipseconder
Network
followed by components of ipsec
modes of Ip security
as for the last topic we will look into
working steps involved in IP security
let's begin with the first setting that
is what is ipsec
ipsec Internet Protocol security is
defined as a set of framework and
protocol to ensure data transmission
over a network channel
this protocol was initially defined of
two main protocols for data security
over a network channel which were
authentication header
which is responsible for data integrity
and anti-replay services
and the second protocol is encapsulating
security payload in short ESP which
includes data encryption and data
Authentication
now let's move on to the next setting
that is why do we use ipsec in a network
ipsec is used to secure sensitive data
and information such as company data
clinical data Bank data and various
sensitive information regarding an
institution
which are used during data transmission
over a network channel
the use of vpns that are virtual private
networks and apply ipsec protocols to
encrypt the data for end-to-end
transmission
let's continue with why do we use ipsec
services
ipsec is also used to encrypt data for
application layer in the osm model and
provide security for sharing data over
Network routers and data Authentication
let's take a look at the working of
ipsec services
to begin with we have two different
systems system 1 and system 2. which
will establish a network channel
and then the encryption of data will
takes place when one host will share the
data to the second host
during this
ipsec services will secure the data that
is to be transferred over the network
channel
by applying router encryption and
Authentication
now let's move on to the next topic that
is components of ipsec
the ip6 services comprises of multiple
protocols that ensure the data
transmission
over the network channel the first one
is encapsulating security payload
protocol in short ESP
this protocol of Ip security provides
data encryption and authentication
services
and it also authenticates and encrypt
the data packet in the transmission
Channel
moving on we have authentication header
in short ah
similar to ESP the authentication header
also provides all the security services
but it does not encrypt the data it also
protects the IP packet and adds
additional headers to the packet header
the modified IP datagram looks this way
where the IP components are included at
the second position
the seventh position and the sixth
position
along with the authentication of data
services over the network channel
moving on we have
internet key exchange Ike
this protocol provides protection for
Content data and also changes the
attribute of the original data to be
shared
by implementing sha and md5 algorithms
they also check the message for
authentication and then only is
forwarded to the receiver site
for example this is the original data
packet we are used to with IP header
path TCP UDP and data
whereas this is the modified ipsec data
packet where a PSP header is added
between IP header and the TCP protocol
now let's move on to the next heading
that is modes of ipsec
there are basically two types of ipsec
modes available for data transmission
over the network channel
where the first one is tunnel mode this
mode of transmission is used to secure
gateway to Gateway data
it is applied when the final destination
of the data is to be connected to a
sender site through a connection Gateway
over the internet
for example we have two host host a and
host B through the host a we are sending
a message to host B which will pass
through a Gateway at host a point
and it passes through a gateway to ghost
B then
this is a basic format for Gateway to
Gateway data transmission
and the given IP datagram format is used
for tunnel mode
now let's move on to the second mode of
ipsec that is transport mode
this mode of ipsec is used to protect
protocols like TCP or UDP and is used to
ensure end-to-end communication unlike
tunnel mode
the transport mode data at
authentication header and encapsulating
security payload for security purpose in
the IP header
this is the modified IP datagram for
transport mode the point to be noted is
the ipsec header is always added between
IP header and TCP header
now let's move on to the last setting
for the session on ipsec that is the
working steps involved in IP security
in general there are five steps involved
in the working of ipsec to ensure data
transmission over a network channel
the first step is post recognition in
the first step the host system will
check if the packet is to be transmitted
or Not by automatically triggering the
security policy for the data which is
implemented by the sender side for
proper encryption
then the second step is known as
Ike phase one in this step the two host
devices the sender and the receiver side
will authenticate each other to
establish a secure network channel
it is comprised of two modes
the main mode this provides much better
security with a proper time limit
and the second mode known as aggressive
mode as the name suggests it establishes
the ipsec protocol much faster in
comparison to main mode
let's move on to the third step which is
Ike phase 2.
after the second step the host decide
the type of cryptography algorithm to
apply over the session in the network
channel
and the secret key for the algorithm to
be used to encrypt the data for
transmission
then we have ipsec transmission this
step involves the actual transfer of
data over the network channel
using various protocols used in ip6
security
which are implemented under the tunnel
condition
and the last step is ipsec termination
after the completion of data exchange or
session timeout the ipsec terminal is
terminated and the security key
established is discarded by both the
hostess thank you for joining us in this
cyber security crash course we have
delved into the ramps of DDOS attacks
explored the entry cases of hashing and
honor skills in penetration testing if
you found this video enlightening don't
forget to hit the Subscribe button gives
us a thumbs up and share it with fellow
digital adventurers
let's build a safer digital world
together and now let's take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers
[Music]
too old to learn anything new whether
it's an art a new language a new sport
or learning new skills to advance your
career
hi I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old and last
year I upskill with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the I.T sector
in various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course oh funny story I want to
share with you
I started off as fine to be a DJ where I
became interested in electronic stereo
systems and how they connected and how
they operate and what made them function
and four years ago I began a journey to
understand and learn more about the
cloud on the way I developed a natural
understanding of the security needs and
began to focus my studies to understand
more about the cyber security aspect of
the cloud landscape
I work with many companies before the
security analyst and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at particulars in college
and been in many different learning and
training experiences but the experience
as a student is simply learning
something I will always cherish of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors that I
believe in living a fulfilling life at
61. I am still training students in
martial arts I've been practicing
martial arts for the past 40 years and
my efforts were acknowledged by the
Eastern United States International
Martial Arts Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication Services martial arts I've
been many things in my life
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first
until next time stay safe keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign